Sobe no meu chat aqui. Só um minutinho.
Cadê o meu chat?
Participantes, chat.
Right. Pronto.
Pronto.
Beleza.
Tudo certo.
Tudo certo. Vamos, começ.
Tá? Então, hoje a gente vai falar um pouco de decomposição.
E eu vou trazer para vocês. Por que eu separei um dia inteiro para falar sobre decomposição.
Mas não decomposição. Só no quesito de você.
Decompor uma especificação em tarefas. Mas como isso acontece por debaixo dos planos? Por quê?
Uma vez que você entenda.
Que a grande sacada para você é.
Traduzir tudo o que você quer. Todas as especificações e processos que a gente fez.
In Small By Chunks. A gente ia começar a ver como que a Llm pode, de fato, executar essa atividade com muito mais.
Precisam ir à curácia.
Então, no primeiro dia, a gente falou muito de prompt contexto.
No segundo dia, a gente falou.
Sobre literalmente entender todos os pormenores, né?
Dos que significa criar um plano.
Planejar quebrar. A gente. Falou sobre. Sim, Swim Lane.
Legs e assim por diante. Mas no final do dia, o que você quer? Você quer transformar um Spec.
E você quer quebrar ele para que você possa trabalhar de formas separadas. E muita gente teve dúvidas sobre isso.
A questão que, no final do dia, que a gente tem que entender.
é que, assim como o ser humano, essa é a grande questão. Sempre vai cair e convergir para isso que Eu Quero Que Vocês Entendam.
é muito mais fácil um ser humano ou uma máquina.
Agir em algo pequeno do que em algo que tem um escopo muito grande.
Então o que a gente está tentando entender? Enquanto a gente vai aprendendo Lms: e tudo isso novo.
é que, no final do dia, uma máquina se comporta muito, muito.
Igual a um ser humano, porque ela é treinada numa rede de Transformers numa rede neural.
Então ela tem esse conceito de alucinação, que nós também, como seres humanos, temos.
Então ela faz um mimicing disso.
Então é importante você entender que.
No final do dia, a gente está tentando.
Usar esses mesmos comportamentos.
Então o que eu vejo no campo.
é que quando você tem uma Llm, independentemente do que seja, tá.
é.
E você não passa instruções muito bem definidas para ela.
Você não tem bons resultados. Então o seu resultado numa Llm ou num sistema gêntico, está diretamente.
Diretamente relacionado à qualidade da sua especificação.
Então isso é certo. E isso é cem para.
Tudo e para todos.
Quanto mais detalhe eu adiciono, quanto mais características quanto.
Mais insumo. Eu dou insumo, correto.
Melhor. Eu tenho de retorno.
Então, no primeiro dia, a pergunta era literalmente, quanto que a gente vendeu no dia anterior.
E quanto que o Ceo, o Cfo pode acreditar naquela informação?
Depois a gente falou: pô beleza.
trabaalia.
de ingenario.
Si plando.
um, plano.
A cheat constuiu, na, nous premier o dire, esa passes de contestantologia.
The boys are Jinqi.
Leto.
Cette.
a memoria.
marketo.
Ta voce come esa controlla.
Como que o se o jarnes vai comporta.
Soaki naorinkinos, entendemos o contesto.
A gente viu que existem algumas coisas bloqueadas que o humano no loop precisa atender.
Então, quando a gente foi olhar o plano.
Esse plano. Na verdade, ele tem alguns impedimentos para a gente. Realmente.
Seguir com ele, porque a gente não tem certas definições importantes, e a gente precisa dessas definições para seguir.
Então, o que vai acontecer agora.
A gente vai explorar.
Todo esse material.
Então.
Hoje a gente vai ver.
Como que vocês podem levar para casa.
E como vocês podem entender, qualquer trabalho feito.
Que será delegado para um agente. E a parte legal é multiagentes e multiharness, né?
Então como que eu deleggo uma atividade para o Codecs? Como que eu deleggo uma atividade para o Cloud. Se Vocês Olharem Na Realidade Hoje Na Vida Real é O Seguinte.
Se você quem aqui trabalha com Codex, fala, eu.
Só para eu saber quantas pessoas utilizam o codec.
Uma pessoa só de duzentos e vinte. Não, muita gente não é legal.
Vou começar essa semana. Boa.
Tá então a galera do Códex.
Quem é a galera que utiliza o Cloud, ou mais conhecido como cloudinho, né?
Beleza. Então, o que eu quero que vocês entendam, né? Talvez vocês utilizem os dois, ou até mais.
No final do dia, são llms diferentes de famílias diferentes, que se comportam diferentes.
E o que eu quero dizer com isso? A forma como que você trabalha no Cloud.
Ele é um pouco diferente de como você trabalha no Códex.
Ele deve ser diferente. Até porque.
Eles atendem propósitos parecidos. Eles têm vários overlappings.
Mas existem características que um faz melhor do que o outro.
Então você só vai entender isso literalmente, com o dia a dia, com a vivência. E o que eu quero dizer com isso?
Eu quero dizer que no final do dia, cara como que a gente consegue, independentemente.
Da Llm que você vai utilizar.
Transformar em uma unidade atômica aquele trabalho.
Então é isso que eu quero que vocês entendam. Isso é canônico.
Então pô de novo refazer todo aquele pedaço para não ficar chato. Poxa, o Luan repete.
Mas eu quero colocar isso na cabeça de vocês, porque uma vez que vocês entendam isso.
O processo. Ele é.
Para todos, sempre. Eu tenho uma requisição.
Essa requisição pode ser uma quantidade de mensagens no Slack. Documentos no Google Drive.
Reuniões. Então pense em tudo. Reuniões.
Que aconteceram documentos que você mesmo fez ou que pediu para ir a fazer. Enfim.
Você tem um mundaréu de documentos onde você vai entender. E você vai curar essa informação junto com a Llm.
Isso vai virar um requisito.
De negócio. Você vai mapear o que toda essa ingestão significa?
Você vai criar esse requisito de negócio.
Esse requisito de negócio vai virar um documento técnico de implementação.
E daí? A gente falou muito.
De Seeing Lame Legs. Mas isso aqui gente é Decomposition.
Então você pode utilizar isso aqui.
Como você pode simplesmente utilizar qualquer forma de decomposição de tarefa?
Você vai decompor algo grande.
Em algo pequeno. é isso que a gente quer fazer. Por quê? Porque, cara, todo mundo vai entender melhor algo Pequeno Do Que Algo Extremamente Gigantesco Ponto Final.
verdad.
Uh, adores.
Um ser meio.
Diferenciado, né? Martin Fowler.
Mas ele fala um pouquinho sobre isso também. Aqui.
é um artigo legal. E no final, você vai ter uma série de coisas de atividades que podem ser executadas. A Gente Vai Ver Isso Logo Mais Beleza.
Então vamos entrar nisso. Aí vamos entender um pouquinho de tudo isso.
Ontem, a gente meio que autorizou e definiu os planos. Hoje, a gente vai literalmente especificar para a execução.
Então a realidade é que a gente tem planos que estão lá, mas que existem certos tipos de aprovação que precisam ser feitas.
Um Spec.
Ele tem duas partes muito importantes.
A que você, como humano, aprova.
E a prova da máquina. Então entenda que quando você cria um Spec, você está criando um contrato.
Da máquina com você ou de você com a máquina. Então pensem nisso, tá? Isso é importante.
Depois. O contexto é finito.
Então, para o contexto ser finito, eu preciso literalmente ter técnicas e formas de fazer isso.
Então, por exemplo, quando a gente olha no princípio, se você falasse para mim, Luan, qual a primeira coisa que eu vou estudar.
Eu passei nessa semana. Eu entendi muita coisa. Eu tenho acesso ao material. Vou conseguir rever isso com calma.
Usar M llm e assim por diante.
Mas olha só. Que interessante.
Se você.
Fosse começar, eu começaria com o conceito de Spec Driven Development.
Porque ele, na verdade, na minha humilde opinião, ele é literalmente a fundação de barro inicial que você precisa.
Está construir fábricas autônomas para construir multiagentes, para construir Harness.
E assim por diante. Porque a partir disso.
Que você vai começar a entender que você vai passar dezassete especificando.
E trinta por cento ali monitorando e vendo. E zero programado.
Então eu começaria com isso. Isso está muito vinculado a você poder utilizar alguns frameworks para te ajudar.
Então a gente tem aqui no mercado Spec Kit.
Spec Kit é um ótimo cara para você.
Usar.
Você tem o Open Spec.
Que é um ótimo cara para você usar.
Você tem o Agent Spec também, que é um cara muito legal para você usar.
Que é uma das versões que eu desenvolvi, justamente com algumas necessidades.
Então cada um deles, no final do dia, vão te oferecer features diferentes. Obviamente.
Mas uma coisa muito legal deles é que seguem sempre o mesmo princípio.
Que é Spectrum Development.
Eu sempre sugiro que se você for começar agora.
Comece pelo Spec Kit.
Aspect tem cento e vinte mil cento e vinte e seis zero estrelas.
Ele cobre muito legal o ciclo de vida. Eles atualizam constantemente.
às seis horas atrás, houve atualizações, tá? Então o cara muito legal.
Eu gosto muito de utilizar o Spec Kit para Greenfield.
é muito bom. Já para Brownfield, para ambientes em que já existem Open Spec é uma proposta muito interessante pela Forma Como Ele Armazena Essas Informações.
E se você já trabalha de forma mais avançada com o Cláudio, por exemplo, o Agents Spec, inicialmente foi desenvolvido Para O Cloud Code Então Ele Funciona Muito Bem Com.
Agente. Sub agente. Base de Conhecimento. Tem algumas coisas muito interessantes aqui, tá? Então.
Só para vocês entenderem sobre esse ecossistema como um todo. Tá.
E aí a gente começa a pensar: bem.
Se, né.
O Spec é literalmente uma das partes mais importantes para a gente começar.
O que isso interfere em todos esses anéis.
Ele interfere na forma com que ele é literalmente a sua comunicação com o modelo.
Então a forma como você vai se comunicar com o modelo é justamente não pelo Prompt, mas pelo Spectrum, você Vai Prompt Para Criar Um Spec.
E isso vai te dar. O quê?
Uma área limpa de trabalho. Isso é importante.
Você se comunicar de forma limpa. E o que é se comunicar de forma limpa é entender o problema.
é só isso que é a parte mais chata que eu diria que é o que todo mundo hoje tem. Preguiça.
As pessoas hoje têm preguiça de entender o problema. Hoje, a gente está tão lnizado.
Essa coisa de fazer várias coisas ao mesmo tempo. Enfim.
Que dificilmente a galera para realmente.
é.
Para entender o problema, né?
E aí aju a Juliana perguntou: pô qual a diferença de um Brown field para um Greenfield, né?
O Greenfield verde. Ele é um campo verde. Então o campo verde é quando não tem nada, ele completamente cru.
Então você está começando um projeto do hoje. Vamos desenvolver um projeto para fazer monitoramento em tempo real do Spark. Vamos.
Qual a ideia? A ideia é essa. E aí você vai desenhar. Vai começar do zero. Isso é um Greenfield.
Um Brownfield. é um ambiente, já que existe alguma coisa. Existe uma fábrica.
Já existe uma aplicação front end.
Já existe todo o processo de deployment em produção, e você vai lá entrar nesse projeto para poder fazer alguma Coisa Essa é A Diferença Entre Os Dois.
Então a definição de. E aí, olha só isso é muito importante. A definição de completo.
é o que falta muito hoje.
O que significa a definição de completa.
Bem, a Helen pode falar para você. O que é a definição de completa.
Mas nesse caso, como o Rafa falou ontem, e eu até enfatizei isso. E ele falou de novo.
A definição de completo tem que ser dada por.
Um Ival. E esse Val deve ser criado. Ele pode até ser criado com uma máquina, mas ele tem que Ser Validado De Alguma Forma Por Um Humano Tem Que Fazer Sentido.
Ou você tem que ter uma forma de validar ou quantificar.
O que esse Val significa. Por isso que a gente passa tempo hoje, analisando, em vez de.
Escrevendo. Então, quando a gente entra dentro de uma especificação de uma tarefa, quebrando ela realmente.
Que a gente começa a ver. A gente começa a ver que uma especificação de tarefa.
Ela tem algumas zonas.
A primeira zona é o quê? é a intenção. Olha só. Que legal.
Beleza é o que e o porquê.
Então, cara, qual é o objetivo? Qual é o contexto dessa sua intenção?
Qual é o esforço para essa intenção que você está literalmente querendo.
O que ele vai tocar. Quais são os impactos que ele tem.
Então eu preciso saber da intenção. Essa é a intenção. Vai ser compilada.
E a gente vai começar a achar dentro dessa intenção.
Todas essas informações que eu falei aqui.
Depois a gente tem uma outra parte muito interessante, que é o comportamento.
Quais são os sinais humanos.
Dado alguma coisa, quando o que a gente vai olhar um pouquinho sobre Bdd.
Get Behavioral. Você vai tentar entender o comportamento e o entendimento do que aquela tarefa significa.
Baseda nisso aqui como se fosse um user Story. Basicamente.
Dentro do user Story. Você tem um pouquinho de intenção, e você tem muito do comportamento.
Ah, quando o comportamento seria. Quando eu clicar nesse botão. Eu quero que aconteça isso. Isso. Isso.
Por exemplo. Então você está definindo um comportamento.
Isso tudo são componentes de como você cria o quê? Uma boa especificação.
Depois você tem um contrato. Essa parte é extremamente.
é importante e não muito olhada hoje.
O contrato é o que a máquina roda. E o que você concorda em relação a isso?
Quais são os critérios de saída desse loop desse pacote que vai ser colocado.
Então está vendo que eu estou decompondo ao nível de chegar na tarefa.
Então eu quero chegar na tarefa. Dia um, a gente passou aqui dia dois. A gente passou por aqui.
Dia três. A gente está. O quê? Falando da tarefa, esse é o nosso ciclo. Essa é a nossa caminhada.
Porque essa caminhada e eu adoro falar isso. Ela é o quê?
Canônica.
Você usa para qualquer projeto.
Pô. Isso é muito legal.
So the Proclock care pressure.
Ah, pô. Eu tenho um software.
Beleza, engenharia. Ai, Engineering.
O que você quiser. Pode ser feito exatamente dessa forma. Todos os problemas que a gente tem, todos eles. Tá.
Indifere.
O Kiro também é um ótimo cara, inclusive, tá, e a gente tem. Por último, a zona quatro.
Que são os limites, os guardo rails que a gente chama os boundings.
As relações, né?
Quais são as coisas que eu não posso fazer.
Quais são as perguntas que não foram definidas? Talvez qual o meu plano de Rollbacks a essa atividade não for Feita Ou Algo Do Tipo.
Só que a gente está olhando.
Que na vida real, a gente faz o quê? A gente abre um ambiente de desenvolvimento.
A gente tira as coisas da nossa cabeça.
Esse gasto energético é muito grande, porque a gente não tem um procedimento.
Então a ideia aqui é criar um procedimento para a gente.
Olha só. Que coisa legal.
Imagina que se a gente abrir os nossos documentos aqui, então vamos dar uma.
Então vamos dar uma olhadinha nos nossos documentos que a gente tem.
Então eu estou dentro do repositório. O repositório está completamente atualizado. Tá.
Então a gente vê histórias de que vamos relembrar a prática. Vamos ver realmente a realidade.
Nós temos cinco documentos. O primeiro documento. Vamos revisar aqui, porque no final das contas, nós somos o quê?
Ai, native Engineers, que estamos realmente construindo esse sistema.
Do zero, guiando esse sistema inteiro, criando esse contrato entre nós e a máquina.
Então a gente viu que o primeiro documento que a gente fez foi de contexto. A gente fez uma investigação E Gerou Um Contexto.
O segundo documento foi para a gente ter disponível uma base de ontologia.
E aí consumida essa informação ontológica, para ter o significado do que.
Realmente aquela informação no banco de dados significa no final do dia, o que aquela métrica realmente significa para o negócio.
Para que a máquina possa entender.
importances.
para um sitee.
Lacional.
duos grants.
Net swim lanes, lingers, neonado.
aparte de transformacao.
Aounder transforma.
Okay, apart technique, cria.
E uma otra su Eleni.
de que.
G blin that severe.
Ito.
Mente.
dependentemente tellas.
Mas.
Apriori voce portra la alitermiche segregado comedos. E veja so.
O nosso item sete. Aqui, ele fala o seguinte.
Nosso item sete.
Ele fala que a gente vai criar um Marte dele. Gross ordered.
Que é a soma.
Pelo campo. Ordered at.
Pedidos não cancelados na granularidade do dia.
Que foi envelopado como uma. O quê?
Uma janela. Técnica.
Então, basicamente, eu estou falando.
Eu estou mencionando que vai ser feito. Olha só está vendo que eu estou mencionando? Eu estou mencionando o que vai ser feito.
E quais são as evidências que eu tenho nessa informação?
Então, se a gente olhar ali.
O que a gente tem no set.
A gente tem basicamente as informações que a gente viu ali.
E a gente tem uma evidência aqui.
A evidência no set é o status. é o seguinte.
é um briefing. é um candidato.
No valor.
De mais de um bilhão, eu acho. Um milhão. Enfim, oitocentos e sessenta e oito pedidos.
E o estado é. A granularidade está bloqueada. Por quê? Porque a gente ainda não entende.
Qual é o conceito.
Do pagamento como um todo, o que a gente considera como pagamento, o que significa.
Essa métrica para a gente de Revenue como um todo.
Beleza. O que a gente poderia fazer.
Para transformar. E é aí que vem.
O primeiro foda do Dia.
Isso aqui. De certa forma, é um Spec. Concordam.
é uma Spec. é uma especificação de algo que você quer.
Realmente fazer. Só que você concorda comigo que essa Spec, obviamente não te pode trabalhar ela em vários granularidades.
Mas ela é algo Open Scope.
Então um dos problemas que eu comecei a ter. E isso aqui é Boots on the Ground Boots on the Ground é A Experiência Das Trincheiras Tá.
Por que eu parei de utilizar Spec Driven Development? Ninguém me perguntou isso. Acho que alguém até fez essa pergunta. Por Que Você Está Usando Mais E Tal Enfim.
Eu parei de utilizar Spectrum Development.
Porque no nível que a gente está hoje.
Por exemplo, se vocês olharem hoje como que o cloud, como que o Codecs se comportam realmente.
Você vai ver. O quê? Você vai ver que eles utilizam sub agentes para fazer.
Então eles invocam vários subagentes. Esses subagentes são nastings.
Uma sub agente pode chamar outro sub agente. Ele pode ir. Três, quatro níveis. Níveis na hierarquia.
Então isso quer dizer o quê? Que você está tentando chegar no nível mais granular da atividade? Cara, isso foi Um Breakthrough Pra Mim.
Muito foda até alguém falar. Ah, foi excitante. Existem alguns, ah, moments na minha carreira.
Moment. Eu escrevi muito. Spec.
Eu passei três, quatro meses escrevendo Speck o dia inteiro e revisando Speck o dia todo.
E daí? Eu comecei a ver que os Specs, utilizando Spec Kit Agent Spec Open Spec.
Por mais que eles sejam muito bons.
Olha o momento, foda.
Eles são textos.
Que implicam uma necessidade.
Sem nenhum tipo de garantia.
Física.
Ou quantitativo.
Então, se a gente abrir ali o Spec Kit maravilhoso, você tem um ótimo descrição do que significa. Enfim.
Mas ainda não é nada literalmente maquinável. Ou seja.
Você não tem uma certeza absoluta de que aquele texto.
Ele vai se transformar na atividade que você quer. Faz sentido o que eu estou falando? Vocês estão seguindo isso Aqui é Muito Importante Para Vocês Entenderem Um Salto.
A gente vai fazer um salto de especificação.
Para a intenção.
Atomicidade. Eu quero que.
Quem tiver dúvida. Aqui.
Pergunte porque o tema principal do dia de hoje é esse. Na hora que você desbloquear isso.
Você vai começar a ver sistemas agênticos de uma forma completamente diferente.
Você vai começar a ver de dentro para fora, em vez de fora para dentro. Ou seja, em vez de Criar Especificação Como Um Todo Você Vai Desenhar O Que Significa Ser Atômico.
E vai quebrar o sistema em pedaços para você conseguir entregar.
Então coloque aqui no chat. Para mim faz sentido. Sim ou não?
E se não faz, eu quero parar.
Para poder responder para vocês no chat.
Porque isso é o salto de hoje. Se vocês não entenderem isso, vocês não vão entender. Daqui pra frente.
Chuck falou o seguinte: sndei a porta de entrada para o ambiente agêntico perfeito.
Mas você quer dar um salto depois, quando percebe que ele não trabalha bem. Multiagêntico, muito boa, muito boa interpretação.
Então você tem uma ótima especificação.
Mas ela é muito grande. Ela pode significar várias coisas. E no final do dia, é texto.
E a Llm pode falar para você o seguinte. Eu fiz.
Qual é a prova irrefutável do que foi feito.
Ah, quer ver uma parada que vai explodir a mente de vocês? Ah, mas eu criei.
Uma validação, um objetivo para falar, que.
Ela tem que verificar o arquivo quando completar.
Beleza. Ela pode criar o arquivo.
Datamart Sql.
E falar que foi completada.
E o conteúdo lá dentro.
Cadê o computador? Do lado.
Isso acontece, tá? Eu não tô falando. Coisas que não acontecem. Não.
Isso acontece. Isso é real.
Você quer descer um grão menor de especificação? Exatamente. E não só descer.
Eu quero que nós.
Modelos e pensemos desde o primeiro momento.
No corte do sistema e nas menores unidades dele. Então, primeiro, eu vou planejar cortar.
Desenhar. E depois eu vou especificar.
Está exatamente, Andrei? Muito bom. Muito boa, boa, parabéns.
Muito bom. Muito bom. Palmas para o Andrei! Aí, gente. Muito bom.
Você quer deixar de ser apenas texto?
Basicamente, eu quero parar de ser apenas texto.
E eu quero dar algo mais conclusivo, especificado, direcionado.
Uma coisa é certa. Essa semana, eu comecei.
Ver alguns comentários e postagens de que Spec.
Acaba logo logo. O que vai importar? A intenção. Exatamente o que o Luan.
Esteja repassando a nova mentalidade que outros ainda estão pensando.
E já estava adotando compose, pegando a menor parte possível e compondo até chegar à solução completa. Mas porque achei Mais Fácil Entender O Problema E Desenhar A Solução.
Já teve que fazer mais de um corte no sistema. Já vários sete, oito tipos de cortes diferentes. Eu vou mostrar para vocês.
I think. Dessa forma geral, especificação, quebrar as tarefas, gerar prompts com os contextos, revisar tudo, revisar novamente.
Executar tudo lindo. Mas na hora de testar, começam a ser os problemas. Muito bom, Hilke. E esse é o Processo Do Spectrum Development Não Está Nada Errado.
é perfeito. O que você fez? Entendeu? Decompôs quebrou, executou, fez só que da hora que literalmente você vai.
Executar. Opa, calma aí. Não fiz isso. Opa.
Ele não. De fato, completou tudo.
Ele gastou muito Token. Ele gastou muito tempo.
Cercando. Mas ele não entregou. De fato.
E um pouco de conceito antigo de funções e componentes interligados ao estado do sistema.
Faz bastante sentido. Dúvidas genuína. Qual relação do Brief Spec com o Task Spec com outra Spec, que virá depois.
O Brief Spec é para você receber leitura da Llm. é para você digerir leitura da Llm.
O Task Spec é para você transformar.
Uma ideia. Ou transformar uma necessidade numa tarefa atômica de execução.
Para qualquer sistema genético executar.
Coisas diferentes.
Muito boa. Esse ponto do André também tinha a percepção que o Spec ser amplo para grandes entregas. Agora faz Muito Mais Sentido Ter Testes Exatamente Eventualmente O Que Você Quer.
Tarefas atômicas. O Rafa está trabalhando, mas depois eu vou chamar ele aqui para falar um pouquinho dessa experiência que ele também teve.
Eu lembro do Rafa falar. Cara, eu não consigo usar o que o Luan faz.
Que era parte de Spec. Então eu estava fazendo muita Spec. O Rafa já estava fazendo um pouquinho mais de.
Decomposição de tarefa, até pela necessidade do ambiente dele. Dada a característica do problema dele.
Então ele já estava pensando, pô.
Cara. Eu preciso passar pequenas atividades.
Incrementais para os meus agentes trabalharem.
E aí? Depois eu quero que o Rafa fale um pouquinho. Rafa, quando você puder falar um pouquinho disso.
Que acho que é um momento de virada aqui para a galera entender.
O Spec para a tarefa. Você pode falar um pouquinho da sua experiência no projeto global extremamente complexo. Que você está fazendo aí.
Claro, no nosso projeto aqui. Na verdade, quando a gente recebe a demanda.
A demanda vem como uma macrodanda e.
A gente começou. Comecei a conversar muito com o Luan em relação a como a gente conseguia fazer isso. Na época Ele Estava Desenvolvendo Se Eu, Não Me Engano Agents Spec Ainda.
Isso.
Acertar a mão para fazer com ele. Que ele não tinha alguns requisitos que o que eu precisava. Então.
Eu comecei a estudar muito isso já tem uns cinco meses e comecei a entrar muito na parte de graça.
E uma.
Como é que.
Um edge. E esse. E essas tarefas seriam correlacionadas por nós.
O que eu acabei fazendo foi fazendo uma evolução do Agent Spec. Onde.
De você passa nesse mesmo processo igual. Eu falei ontem. Eu acabei entendendo que, na verdade, cara, ninguém desenvolve. Então A Minha Equipe Todo Mundo.
Obrigado a usar Copilet, então muito mais complexo de usar em relação ao desenvolvimento do que o Cloud Code.
You Codex. E acabava que minha equipe estava jogando tudo em cima do Copa se perdendo muito. Então que eu Acabei Fazendo Foi Cara Vou Desistir De Fazer A Liberação O Tratamento Interno De Uma Spec.
Passagem voltadas para a gente. Então foi o primeiro contato que eu tive com o Okf, que, na verdade, a Golden Tinha Lançado Ainda Então Eu Já Tinha.
Segundo o Cloud Codecode, aquilo ali foi o primórdio do. Ok. Então eu já usava isso.
E ele montava um roteiro documentado que tanto os agentes quanto os Juanes conseguiam ler. Então, depois que ele disse Que Estava Montado Ele Passava Por Um Gate De Validação.
Engage. Uma vez validada, ele quebrava isso em várias tarefas. Então é exatamente o que o Luan chama de.
Estava desenvolvendo sem se falar. Eu desenvolvi a mesma coisa, só que eu chamei de tracks. Então ele foi para A Natação E Eu Fui Pra Coração.
E.
E você não corre, né? Esse é o pior.
Exatamente aí. Eu montei as Trecks.
E nem eu nado.
Exagerada.
Mas enfim, eu acabei montando. Ele quebrava a tarefa em Trecks. E cada track. Ela trabalhava com nós e Ads Ali Dentro Vinculando As Tarefas E.
Cada uma tinha um gate de validação. Então eu tinha dois regras no sistema básicas. O Intention tinha que ser Muito Bem Montado E Validado Por Dois Agentes Então Ele Passava Por Dois Modelos Diferentes E No Final.
Cada tarefa. Ele tinha que ter uma validação Green. Então ele tinha um Evol de validação. No final de cada tarefa.
Ele só passava de uma tarefa, ou seja, de um Ed para o outro. Ed. Assim que o nó ficasse disponível.
Então é como se fosse uma troca de bastão. Aquela corrida com troca de bastão. Então a ideia foi basicamente essa.
Ele pega, quebra tudo isso em várias tarefas menores, como se fosse text back. Bem, peças tarefa valida, tá ok. Ele passou o Bastão para a próxima tarefa, a próxima tarefa faz e ele vai aí. No final, ele pega todas as Treks Junta Tudo E Faz Uma Validação Geral.
Então Ele Está Entregue Quando Ele Faz A Entrega Ele Tem Dois Agentes Novamente Que Faz Um Processo De Learning ele chega e tem um repositório aqui dentro do Deliver Graph, que fala, ok, tudo que eu aprendi nesse processo, tudo que eu fiz E Todas As Regras Que Eu Criei Ele Documenta Tudo Isso Dentro De Um.
De um. Ok, um processo de estilo. Ok.
Na próxima vez. Ele faz isso novamente.
Então a ideia, exatamente é muito parecido com converges. Só que ele tem um pouco dessa guinada de entrada e Saída Bem Definida E O Meio Do Processo Ele é Totalmente Agênico.
E não somente isso. O Rafa.
Utilizava Graph Engineering antes de existir Graph Engineering. Só vocês terem ideia do nível do cara.
Isso é conhecido como Graph Engineering.
Hoje. Mas ele já usava isso há cinco meses atrás.
Então. Mas o engraçado de tudo isso é que ambos nós convergimos na mesma ideia. Rafa.
Que é decompor uma atividade.
Por que você pensou em decompor.
Esse bando de requisitos chegando numa microatividade. Foi pelo multiharnes.
Foi pela necessidade da complexidade de cada uma dessas tarefas, que eram bem complexas. E você queria um nível de granularidade exato.
Foi para você conseguir colocar o Eval em cada uma delas. Por que você começou a pensar em reduzir.
Eu tive algumas regras. Primeiro, que quanto mais quanto menor a atividade, mais específica ela for, melhor o agente de Trabalho Então Assim Se Você For Quebrar Isso Em Documentos.
Development. Se você tentar fazer isso, você quebrava Spec. Depois a Dr. Depois. Não sei o que. Não sei o Que Isso Era Muito Muito Moroso E No Final Das Contas, Você Quando Jogava Isso Pra Gente Você Perde o Controle Do Que O A Gente Está Fazendo.
Porque O Agente Vai Fazer O Que Ele Quer Tudo Depende De Como Ele Foi Treinado Então Se Ele Foi treinado com uma determinada característica de design pattern. Ele vai ter esse viés e o entendimento que a gente já tem há alguns meses é Que O Llm Em Si é Indiferente Nesse Processo.
Tem uns que são melhores que outros. Mas no final das contas, cada.
Ele tem um pré treinamento e um pós treinamento que direciona ele melhor para um tipo de tarefa. E foi Quando A Gente Começou A Conversar Sobre O Metaharness.
Que Foi Antes Do Databix Lançar Isso E Tudo Mais Então A Gente Já Se Falava E Não Eu Não quero um Harness. Eu quero um cara que controle Harness, que são agentes controlando agentes que fazem deploys para modelos. E tem a resposta Face à Autovalidação E Me Coloquem No Loop Só Quando Ele Realmente Não Precise.
Então a ideia foi essa. Então, quanto menor a unidade de tarefa que você está passando para o agente, mais Fácil é A Validação.
Problema que eu comecei. Usar gráfico. Nesse caso, fazer o Graph não foi exatamente o tamanho da tarefa. Foi como As Tarefas Se Comunicavam.
Vezes, uma tarefa tinha dependência de outras e outras tarefas. Elas não tinham dependência. Aí eu acabei criando um gráfico, que é onde.
Para Quem Conhece Gráfico São Nós E Edes Pontas Que Eles Se Comunicam Como Se Fosse Uma Rede Social Então eu montava como se fosse uma rede social de tarefas e uma vinculada à outra, sendo que uma mostrava dependências em relações a outras E No Final Das Contas.
Quando todas as dependências estivessem finalizadas e válidas, ele aceitava. Aí sim, ele fazia o uni teste, um meta e Vol Para Validar Tudo Então Ele Fazia O Aceite Da Entrega.
Então a ideia era realmente diminuir para dar menos trabalho para os agentes e subagentes.
So.
Obrigado, Rafa. Agora pode focar aí. Acho que agora ficou.
Cristal. Porque faz sentido. Porque deixa me coloca aqui no chat.
Conseguiram entender.
Beleza. Vamos lá, gente. Digitem.
ótimo. E aí, o que a gente começou a fazer, né?
Então a gente olhou algo que é texto, e a gente começou a pensar o seguinte: Bem.
E se eu começar a dar algumas características para esse.
Nível aqui. Então, primeiro, qual o esforço dessa atividade?
Isso é importante, porque o esforço pode me dizer qual era a Lm que eu posso mandar.
Depois. Quais são os Peffs que ela toca?
Isso é importante para eu ter rastreabilidade. Para saber exatamente o que ela vai fazer.
Eu quero capturar. Qual intenção? Essa intenção é uma intenção humana, com um objetivo, com o contexto.
O comportamento é humano. Também eu quero saber quando. Porquê.
E aí a gente vai criar um contrato.
é onde eu vou ter uma validação, um cartão e um critério de saída. Porque eu tenho um loop dentro desse cara.
Depois. Quais são os guardrails? Quais são os Boundaries? Quais são os limitadores que eu tenho.
Depois. Quais são as perguntas operacionais que eu tenho que podem ser feitas.
Bem como que eu capturo observabilidade disso.
Quantos tokens foram usados? Quantas peças foram feitos? Qual esforço disso?
Qual o meu plano de Holdback, caso não funcione?
E para mim, a parte mais interessante do Task Spec.
Que eu não vi em nenhum lugar ainda.
é o Ceiling. é o Seal.
O que o Task Spec faz. Isso aqui é muito foda, Rafa. Eu acho que eu nunca te expliquei isso.
Ele faz essa atividade.
Ele faz um Hmec. Ele faz um Shad dois cinquenta e seis e ele loca. Ele faz um Seal.
Desse cara. Então, na hora em que um agente pega, ele lê a chave criptográfica.
E ele pega essa atividade. Se houver qualquer injeção ou qualquer coisa, a tarefa é excluída.
Porque aquele agente foi assinalado para aquela atividade. Não consigo fazer hijacking. Eu não consigo fazer injeção. Eu não consigo fazer nada.
Eu não tenho um agente interpolando o outro no contexto.
Ela fica completamente alinhada.
Com esse cara. Se houver qualquer um tentando alterar, ele faz um temperin.
E aí ele dá um lock e remove a atividade. Você não pode executar mais.
Eu copiei isso aí do Dge. Já tá.
é legal, né? Bem interessante.
Eu também já copiei muita coisa.
Essa é a parte legal. A gente fica se copiando aqui, tá? Então.
O que eu falo. Para cada vez mais. O Rafa pensa dessa forma. Eu penso dessa forma. No final, deu composição. Ou seja.
A gente entende os fundamentos. Então você criou a sua própria forma de trabalhar.
E aí eu falo, cara, eu tenho esse Framework Llm. Dá uma olhada nesse outro Framework.
Veja as coisas aqui que são legais de trazer e vice versa.
Então você tem isso, tá.
Beleza. Então você tem esse tipo de entrega aqui.
E aí, quando a gente começa a olhar o nosso plano.
O que a gente começou a entender.
Que a gente tem um projeto inicial do Dbt.
Que a gente tem alguns pontos que são bloqueados.
Que a gente ainda não tem todas as informações que a gente precisa.
E a gente precisa definir o que significa completo.
E aí a gente começa a pensar o seguinte: em números.
Como que o humano.
Trabalha, pensa e delega informação.
Então, literalmente, o que a gente começa a entender.
é que.
Eu preciso ter um conhecimento muito bom do negócio ou do problema que eu estou atacando.
Para literalmente conseguir definir qual é a estratégia que eu vou fazer.
E quando a gente começa a olhar, por exemplo, a ideia da especificação.
A gente tem, por exemplo, dentro do Spec Driven.
A parte da especificação.
Planejamento.
Tarefas e implementação. Então, quando você olha para isso, você vai pensar: Poxa.
Mas o Task.
Mas o Spectrum Development. Ele já tem tarefas lá dentro.
Sim, só que tarefas? é uma parte do processo do Specimen Development.
A tarefa em si não é olhada no mesmo mecanismo.
Ele utiliza a tarefa.
Mas ele não tem esse nível.
De seriedade do que significa uma tarefa como um todo.
Então a primeira ideia é.
Planejamento é diferente da execução.
Então o planejamento acontece em uma camada, e a execução acontece numa outra camada.
Então, se a gente olhar, por exemplo, o item sete.
Tem o nosso item sete aqui. Ele está para Review.
Só que se você simplesmente pedir para a gente fazer o que ele pode fazer, ele pode olhar para esse Item Aqui Que Está No Plano E Ele Fazer O Quê.
Ele implementar esse item.
Sendo que nós não demos a característica por ele.
E aí vocês vão falar. Por quê? Porque isso aqui é texto. Não tem nada que me impeça de eu Executar Essa Atividade Ou Que Foi Falado Nesse Documento Aqui.
Então, o que a gente precisa entender? A gente precisa entender como conectar.
Essa. Esse plano com, literalmente algo executável.
E começar a pensar em como a gente pode construir.
Essa atividade. Então vamos dar uma olhadinha na primeira parte do nosso processo.
Que é literalmente olhar o ambiente como um todo e verificar se nós temos todos aqueles arquivos realmente.
Então a gente vai vir aqui.
E lembra que para ficar, quem ficar aqui até o final, vai ter acesso ao Task Spec. Eu vou fazer A Mesma Coisa Como Eu Fiz No Brief Spec.
Eu vou abrir. Vocês fazem download. E hoje eu puxei um update gigantesco Rafa. Depois você dá uma olhada.
Muito grande. Um ambiente de. Acho que de trinta e cinco mil linhas, aproximadamente. Eu fiz muita modificação legal.
Nele. E eu vou falar como que eu fiz isso hoje. Foi bem legal.
Tá? Então aqui a gente vem em Live.
D, tres.
E aí a gente vai nessa primeira tarefa.
Aqui a gente vai basicamente verificar as evidências, né?
Se todas aquelas informações que literalmente a gente falou. Elas estão aqui.
Então eu quero preparar algumas coisas que a gente vai utilizar.
Então eu quero verificar. Por exemplo, se eu tenho alguma pasta temporária criada, eu quero remover alguns arquivos que talvez Possam Ter Sido Criados.
Eu quero verificar se eu tenho Make Stars.
Se realmente o ambiente está operacional. E aqui eu quero verificar se o Task Spec está instalado. A gente vai Ver Sobre Isso Também.
Já. Já fica tranquilo. Então eu vou abrir o terminal.
Eu vou executar.
Beleza.
Vamos verificar se eu tenho tudo aqui, então as tabelas estão no sistema, então.
Como se eu estivesse consultando essas informações. Live, os documentos que nós geramos estão no repositório.
O escopo. O esqueleto do Dbt está lá dentro.
E a gente tem todo esse cara funcionando. Está tudo operacional no nosso sistema. Então.
Final do dia, meio que verificasse tudo que a gente fez anteriormente. Nos dias anteriores, estavam aqui. Eles estão.
Então a gente está legal para.
Seguir pro próximo passo.
Agora, olha só. Que interessante.
A gente tem três itens.
Desculpa. Dez itens e nós temos tres itens que são bloqueados aqui.
E a gente vai começar a pensar como a gente vai operacionalizar esses itens. Então, o que significa se eu abrir aqui.
Quatro. Ele fala de três itens bloqueados, né?
Olha só, eu tenho o item sete. O item nove e o item dez são bloqueados.
Então existe o quê? Uma dependência? E aí?
Trazendo um pouquinho do que o Rafa falou, né? Você pode ter um grafo de referência que fala, cara, essa é A Atividade Bloqueada Por Essa.
Que é bloqueada por essa, e você cria uma relação sobre isso. Então nós temos três atividades bloqueadas aqui.
Que no Spec. Ela é o quê?
Uma especificação de texto somente então a gente vai entender o seguinte, cara.
Quando a gente olha todas essas tarefas aqui.
Que que a gente tem. ó, a gente pode criar o Stg Customers. Está tudo ok. A gente pode criar o Stg products.
Está tudo ok. A gente pode criar o Stg Orders. Tudo ok.
Stj payments. Também a gente pode criar o documento de reconciliação que integra pedido com pagamento.
A gente pode implementar o Return funds.
Só que quando a gente for literalmente.
Tentar fazer uma venda de margem ordenada.
A gente começa a esbarrar naquele problema que a gente ainda não resolveu no briefing.
Que ele está bloqueado.
E aqui. O que é o Dbt, né? Na engenharia de dados.
A gente. Nós temos várias formas de criar sistemas analíticos, né?
Então, por exemplo, se a gente olha no mundo real hoje de dados, você tem.
Um Sgbd. Vamos botar o ltp para ficar mais mais fácil, né?
Que é um sistema transacional. Então pensa no sistema transacional aqui. Como.
Skill server.
Bullshig.
Mais. Kelly.
Oracle. Isso tem noventa e nove novecentos e noventa e nove nove das empresas.
Toda empresa tem um banco de dados relacional. Eu nunca.
Conversei com uma empresa de médio e grande porte.
E até de pequeno porte cara. A gente não usa banco de dados.
Então.
A gente sempre tem esse cara. Só que isso aqui é um ambiente.
Transacional, onde normalmente você tem aqui. O quê?
Uma aplicação, um app.
Que se comunica com essa.
Com esse banco. Geralmente é Sic. Funciona.
E aí nós, de dados que temos o background.
é.
Gibecional de dados. A gente não consegue fazer análise.
Ou habilitar Ia em grande escala ou fazer processamento analítico dentro da base. Então, o que a gente tem que fazer aqui?
A gente tem que fazer um processo chamado Etl ou Ellt.
Que é para transformar ou mover o dado de um site para um outro site.
E a gente traz isso para um site. Olap.
Que, em vez de ser transacional, online e transactional processing.
A gente traz para algo chamado online analytical processing. Então a gente traz para um ambiente analítico.
E aqui, sendo analítico, a gente tem várias tecnologias aqui.
Para fazer isso. Então a gente tem bancos de dados analíticos. Então, por exemplo, uma ideia que seria Big Query.
Headshift.
Is snowflake.
Data, Brics, Sql.
E assim por diante.
E aqui o que que a gente tem, né?
A gente tem uma tecnologia.
Chamada Dbt.
Que basicamente permite com que você escreva Sql.
E fazer toda essa comunicação com o seu ambiente.
E aí você escreve todas as lógicas, as regras, tudo em Skl.
Em grande escala. Então você pode processar giga mega giga e terabytes utilizando Dbt, que ele é um rapper.
Ele é um cara que você escreve e ele traduz. Basicamente, ele persiste essa informação dentro.
Do seu sistema. A parte legal do Dbt é que se um dia você estiver utilizando Big Query, e depois Você Utilizar Headshift A Transição é Muito Suave.
Então mudar os adapters é extremamente simples de fazer isso. Então, o Dbt é muito utilizado.
E a gente chama isso aqui do seguinte.
A gente só para vocês entenderem, para ficar bem bem interessante.
Essas duas partes aqui. Normalmente, um Sw Faz.
Só para vocês entenderem como que a Ia tem, né?
Feito um brain fuck em todo mundo aqui, né?
Então aqui é o trabalho de um Sw. O que é um Sw? O software Engineer.
O dinheiro que vai construir o frontback que vai construir toda a lógica.
Aqui nesse processo de Tl. Normalmente você tem um de.
Que é o derem dinheiro.
E aqui no Dbt. Normalmente.
Você tem um Analytics Engineer.
Então, só aqui.
Nós temos o quê? Tres Roles.
Que vão ser comidas pelos agentes.
Que a gente vai fazer aqui agora. Então, teoricamente, a gente está aplicando. Não muito. Sw.
Mas a gente está aplicando engenharia de dados para trazer o dado de um lado para o outro.
E está aplicando Analytics Engineering.
Para criar as regras para o Dbt.
Então é basicamente isso.
Então aqui a gente está vendo as regras que a gente vai utilizar com os bloqueios que são resistentes.
Então vamos dar uma olhada num plano.
Para poder atacar esse problema.
Então vamos aqui no plano plausível.
E a gente vai abrir uma sessão que vai ser descartada.
Mas a ideia é o seguinte: um plano.
A gente vai subdividir.
Ele em algumas características. Então, o que eu vou falar dentro.
Do item. Então, o item que a gente tem de bloqueio é o item sete que a gente precisa resolver.
Está bloqueado. Então a gente vai chegar. Abrir. Llm.
E vai falar o seguinte.
Implemente o item sete do plano de transformação no transforme plan Transform. Que é esse.
Marte dele. Groz Orders, Sam, blá, blá, blá, blá, blá, blá, blá. Esse é o problema.
Apresente apenas o seu plano de implementação em, no máximo, seis linhas numeradas.
Não execute nada. E não escreva nenhum arquivo.
Então, o que que a gente está fazendo? Você está vendo que esse processo, ele ainda é muito thought process. Ele é Um Processo Cara.
Criar o contexto.
Pesquisar ontologia, as informações.
Criar o documento técnico.
Depois entender cada tarefa, verificar que existem bloqueios humanos. Isso é o dia a dia.
Esse é o dia a dia do Ai Needs of Engineer do for Deploy Engineer.
Ou do Ai Engineer. Enfim.
E daí? Agora a gente vai trabalhar nos bloqueios.
E aí ele mostrou: aqui, olha.
Bem, eu posso atacar isso dessa seguinte forma aqui, né?
Eu posso atacar isso pensando em fazer um Routing.
Mas está fora do contexto.
Eu posso tentar achar evidências maiores para entender se pedido é diferente de cancelado.
Eu posso simplesmente criar um modelo sobre.
O Stg Orders.
Somando o total e o count agrupados. Então olha aqui. Ele está dando formas diferentes de atacar o mesmo problema.
Eu posso tentar dar um rótulo do que significa descrição Growth Order e assim por diante.
E eu posso tentar fazer alguns testes para verificar se aquele valor é nulo, não é? Ou assim por diante.
E no final, eu posso ter um gate para verificar se esse cara está funcionando realmente.
Então é uma forma de fazer isso.
Obviamente que se eu chegar e fizer essa mesma pergunta, por exemplo, para o codecs.
Vou perguntar para o Grok. Vamos ver se o Grok está aqui. Ele não está aparecendo quatro seis. Não sei por.
Se vocês.
Não usaram Grok quatro seis. Muito bom. Inclusive.
Surpreendente, tá? Então eu vou usar aqui o de psique pro que ele.
Aberto. E vamos ver aqui o que ele vai sugerir, né?
Então aqui, chamando de Daily Gross Other Mart. Aqui também.
Vamos dividir esse cara e vamos ver o que ele vai dar de plano para a gente. Também.
Está vendo que eu já estou mostrando para vocês como entender e trabalhar com multi.
Com multi llms ou assim por diante. Isso é muito legal.
Interessante você saber por quê? Porque você está estudando o fundamento.
Você está entendendo? O quê? O fundamento como um todo.
Essa ideia é o superponto Engineering. é uma ideia para Mac.
Se você não tem Mac, você quer uma ideia agêntica que a gente chama agora de ideagêntica, né?
Aí. Use orca. é uma ótima ideia maravilhosa, inclusive. Tá.
Beleza. Deixa ele gerar aqui. Então foi um plano. Diferentes formas de decompor essa informação.
E daí? O que que a gente teve, né? A gente teve três tipos.
De planos. A gente vai gerar três tipos de planos aqui.
A pergunta é, qual é o plano correto?
O pique significa correto.
A gente estabeleceu, correto? Em qual momento?
Ou seja, se você tem um humano no loop.
Como que, de fato, você consegue garantir que um plano.
Vai ser executado seguindo as regras corretas.
I don't ser que você tenha uma forma de validar isso. Ou seja, a gente mencionou.
Mas não especificou. é daí que a gente começa a entender.
Como que a gente consegue criar um escopo em cima de tudo isso.
E daí a gente começa a pensar: bem, se é atividade.
Vocês entenderam aqui. Se a atividade no seu menor grão.
Ela não pode ser verificável.
Então, qual é o sentido de fato.
De eu passar um Spec inteiro e não conseguir ter uma unidade verificável ou acionável de uma tarefa.
é daí que eu olhei.
E eu entendi cara. A gente precisa não só decompor, mas a gente tem que começar a olhar de dentro Para Fora Não De Fora Para Dentro.
Considerar que uma tarefa.
Ela é um átomo. Ela é uma menor unidade de trabalho.
E agora prestem atenção, porque aqui vai ser muito legal para vocês.
E eu comecei a me perguntar o seguinte.
Essa é a minha ideia. Será que ela faz sentido?
E aí eu obviamente, toda vez que eu tenho uma ideia, eu não uso uma Llm. Só eu uso no Mínimo Três Quatro Llms Para Verificar Se Aquela Ideia é Sound Se Ela Faz Sentido Realmente.
E daí eu comecei a olhar cara.
Será que existe, né.
Alguma relação de entendimento com o que eu falei? Com o que eu estou pensando. No que é realmente.
E aí? Olha só. Que legal. A primeira coisa é.
Em dois mil e vinte e quatro, o modelo era o limite. Realmente, a gente não tinha nem conceito de Harness Ainda A Gente, Não Falava De Voz A Gente, Não Entendia Isso.
As utilizava. Tdd: E esse tipo de coisa. Beleza.
Então, literalmente. Olha só.
Os humanos escrevendo código de A.
Ai. Usava autocomplete.
A capacidade era escassa.
Então o melhor modelo era o melhor output. Realmente verdade total.
Boa pergunta. Cinthia. Sempre usa as três Llms. Não.
Hoje, na época, Sim, eu utilizava muito humanos para fazer esse tipo de pesquisa.
Utilizava o códex para poder fazer a validação disso tudo. E utilizava o Cloud também.
Hoje eu utilizo vários. Então eu pego modelos que eu testo todo dia.
Então, Cloud Grock Kimi.
De Psique.
Minimax, Queen.
Eu acho que isso basicamente. Então eu tenho uma lista aqui. Toda vez eu olho. Tenho aqui no meu Notion.
E daí eu. Quando eu quero fazer uma pesquisa extensa, mesmo eu tiro de todos eles. Tá? Então como que Eu Faço Isso Né.
Eu uso o Open router. Então eu conecto o omipie.
No Open router. E daí eu começo a fazer exatamente esse tipo de coisa.
E aí eu começo a fazer algumas pesquisas em relação a tudo.
Beleza.
Quem testou o Jammy Nine? Tres um.
Muito bom para jogar no lixo.
Minha experiência foi péssima.
Caro.
Muito caro e o resultado foi muito ruim. Foi inversamente proporcional.
Impressionante. Mas, cara, o Minimax. Muito bom. O Grok quatro seis. Excelentíssimo.
O Deep. Psique V quatro nem fala. O Glm é muito bom.
Gosto desses caras. Bastante. Tá.
Beleza em dois mil e vinte e cinco para dois mil e vinte e seis.
A gente começou a entender o quê, cara.
A gente gera código.
Os agentes definem trabalho.
Mas agora, várias.
Indianes podem fazer o trabalho. Lembra que lá para meados de dois mil e vinte e cinco para dois mil E Vinte E Seis O Que Aconteceu.
O Cloud basicamente dominava esse quadrante cara. Então, assim, se você pedisse pra uma outra. Lm: Fazer uma certa atividade.
Você ainda tinha aquela coisa de cara. Será que realmente vai rolar.
E o limite hoje está no quê?
A definição.
Da tarefa é a Constraint. Hoje.
Então a qualidade agora depende altamente de quão claro a tarefa é especificada.
Não ter os detalhes produz o quê? Um.
Plausible. But wrongwork.
Um trabalho errado, plausível.
Então, olha só. Que legal. Esse statements.
Quando o modelo passa o Threshold, a qualidade se torna função da especificação.
E a companenitude dela, não a inteligência do modelo.
Então, o que a gente está olhando agora? De dois mil e vinte e seis para dois mil e vinte e sete.
Decomposição. Então, cara, eu estou ensinando para vocês, geralmente, literalmente. O que está acontecendo lá.
No Bleeding Edge. A gente está num momento de decomposição.
Algumas informações para fazer o backing up disso, né?
A especificação, não a implementação.
é um fator estável. Outra, se a gente for olhar os Specs, que são literalmente o início de tudo isso.
A gente tem uma adoção de oitenta na melhoria de qualidade.
A gente também tem melhorias na definição e decomposição das tarefas, quando nós temos literalmente.
Essa confiança estabelecida entre o Spec e entre o desenvolvimento. Então isso quer dizer o quê? Quanto mais Spec, eu faço.
Melhor documentação e melhor entendimento para a Ll Hammer. Estou passando esse cara.
E aí, o que eu fiz? Eu extrapolei um pouco o que eu fiz esses dias faz algumas semanas.
Eu usei nove llms diferentes para poder olhar o Task Spec, refutar e trazer algumas informações.
Então eu utilizei Sol Glm Grock Queen de psique Kimi Minimax.
Utilizei.
Só e Luna. Utilizei.
Fable Sonitch e Opus quatro oito na época. Eu acho.
E aí, o que a gente tem de três pontos importantes? Qual o veredito, né?
A gente tem um contrato portátil.
Para uma unidade de tarefa.
Não modelo não, Sandbox, não. Agendamento, não. Um tracker.
Então a gente tem literalmente a definição de uma atividade de uma unidade atômica.
Outro ponto. O Eval.
Decide. Donny.
Ou seja, não o que o agente escreveu.
Então o agente escreve. Existe uma outra definição do que realmente é completado.
Tá, eu escrevi. Mas o que realmente significa ser escrito.
é diferente, tá?
E outra coisa. A gente tem fonte aonde parar aonde continuar.
O que fazer e o que não fazer.
Então esse é um outro ponto muito importante desse cara.
Então, olha só o mesmo Job.
Pensando num ticket ou num Spec.
Para um task Spec.
Então aqui eu tenho o título dele. Gross ordered.
O Body. A declaração desse cara.
E Aikeodes foram algumas informações desse meu Speck. Ou nessa minha declaração.
O que seria isso para uma tarefa? O nome da tarefa.
Esforço disponível para qualquer agente.
Quais são as interações de budget que eu tenho? Eu tenho quinze interações que eu posso fazer.
Qual é o documento que vai ser criado.
Qual é o Behavioral dela? ó Given!
A Raw Order with Six Statuses, ou seja, dado.
Um pedido com seis Estados, quando a agregação dos grupos foram ordenadas. At.
Então o status cancelado é excluído.
E a granularidade é pelo nível dia. Eu estou dando comportamento desse cara.
E aí, qual é o evol? Quais são as validações do que significa Donny para isso, né?
Eu tenho conseguido fazer um Make Dbt para verificar se.
Eu compilo o Sql.
Eu tenho que fazer um grap.
Para verificar se eu achei o título.
E eu tenho que verificar se esse modelo realmente existe lá dentro.
E essa atividade foi criada. Ela ainda não foi selada porque não teve ninguém.
Que veio aqui buscar essa atividade, para poder fazer.
Faz sentido só para saber se tá todo mundo na mesma página.
Faz sentido. Então a gente está descendo lá na unidade atômica. Beleza.
E aí existem várias decisões que eu não vou parar aqui para explicar porque a gente vai ter uma sessão só para isso.
De Task Spec, porque aqui é um mundo gigantesco. Mas existem várias coisas que a gente faz dentro do Task Spec.
Então a gente tem o julgamento humano. A gente tem o passing, o contrato feito. E daí? A gente tem A Criação Desse Cara.
Então você vai compilar a intenção.
O comportamento vai ser gerado. Você vai validar esse contrato.
Esse contrato vai gerar todos os guardrails, as operações. E o que é reverso? Fazer isso tudo vai ser envelopado numa atividade.
Selada para que ela possa ser executada por um agente ou não.
Beleza. Então a gente tem todas essas informações. Aqui a gente sela essa atividade.
Então, nesse caso, olha só. Que legal. Eu posso chegar aqui e falar. Task Spec Gate, Stamp.
Eu gero uma estampa naquilo.
E aí eu estou disponível para delegar. E olha só. Que legal sign off true sign off by luan.
Sign off at e sign off at sig, que é o meu.
Que é literalmente o meu Eight, a minha validação. E daí, quando eu faço uma validação dessa atividade.
A gente tem literalmente o tempering dela. Se ela for alterada ou não.
Então eu guardo essa informação, tá? Eu tenho todos os metadados armazenados.
Dentro dessa atividade também.
E aí ela passa por algumas.
Por alguns pedaços, né? Então eu faço.
O autor dessa Atividade.
Ela é validada. Você tem um pré Gate para selar essa atividade. Você tem um hand off para garantir que.
Quem vai utilizar e quando chega na área de execução, a próprio Task Spec.
é inteligente ao nível de falar. Bem, essa atividade pode ser muito bem executada para essa Engines.
Então existe uma base de conhecimento que a gente fala.
Qual é o melhor agente para executar aquela atividade?
Aí a gente está falando de Meta Harness. A gente está falando de um Harness que controla auto Harness. E Uma Vez Que Essa Atividade Aceita.
é criado um Stamp e ela começa a ser executada.
E a gente tem várias outras coisas interessantes aqui. Em relação ao que você consegue fazer.
Você tem níveis de autorização. Você tem níveis de selo.
Você tem níveis de flags que você pode passar.
Cara é um mundo. Então, uma vez que vocês têm o acesso a isso, a ideia é literalmente navegar dentro do repositório.
Entender exatamente o que acontece. E a gente agora vai navegar numa Task Spec, para vocês verem isso em ação.
Então vamos aqui no dois. Task Spec.
Então a gente vai criar uma nova sessão.
E o que a gente vai fazer? A gente vai criar uma pasta chamada Tasks.
E a gente vai criar uma atividade chamada Daily Gross Ordered. Md.
Que é exatamente aquela atividade que a gente precisa resolver, que é o item sete.
Eu já passo para você, Carol, deixa eu só passar aqui, tá?
Então a gente vai vir aqui. E eu estou mostrando isso no dedo na dedalha. Tá.
Então vamos vir aqui.
Clean Slate. Vamos ver se a gente tem a pasta Task criada, não temos? Então a gente vai criar um Novo Folder Tasks Isso é Criado Automaticamente Tá.
Eu estou mostrando como vai ser na mão na vida real. Se você não tivesse.
Então você tem o arquivo Md. E olha só. Que interessante.
Esse é o escopo de uma tarefa básica, tá? Existem milhares de outras coisas aqui.
Mas basicamente. Olha que linda, né.
Você tem o Front Matter, que diz: qual é o Id dessa tarefa? Qual o título dela?
Se ela está disponível. Esforço, interação de budget que você pode fazer.
Nesse momento, ela não depende de ninguém, porque ela é o bloqueador, na verdade, né.
Ela vai criar essa cara.
A fonte dela vem dessa informação para a leitura e entendimento.
Ela foi criada e você tem taggings nela. Então, olha só. Que legal. Qual o objetivo.
Produzir uma agregação. Dele.
De pedidos não cancelados.
Aonde o Label é a base.
Do que.
é a base física e nunca o que significa revenue.
Qual é o contexto? Ele vai ler. O Stg Orders vai ler essas informações.
Vai escrever aqui? Tá vendo? Lembra? às vezes, quando você pede no Wilker, você já viu isso? Quando você fala.
Escreve para mim, tal. Ele decide onde ele vai escrever. às vezes ele escreve dentro de uma pasta. às vezes Ele Escreve Dentro De Outra.
Porque você não tem o contexto. Então aqui você consegue passar exatamente.
Essas informações. Você tem comportamento.
Critério de sucesso.
Cardio de Validação e Exitcheck, que não está aqui ainda, tá. A gente tem anti patern. Tá.
is unresolved. Revenue known for his important.
No talkie, species, no talkies, no temos name. Entao essa e scope initi uma achieve vidade.
Mer.
O fronte meter.
E esa primera pate do documento aqui dento deciamo, deto de se MED,
Y se que muto legao.
Book it.
um my skill.
Condo o cloude o Codex 40 aquilo que voce pegunto feces issue um es que o praquil.
Ele vai preciseudo enteindemuto mais o precompilaca la informacao.
Se ele vai utilizar isso como ski ou se ele vai carregar isso ou não.
Ou seja, é obrigatório que tudo que você faça para os seus agentes tenha um flutimary beleza.
Então aqui eu tenho Front Matter.
Eu especifiquei exatamente o que ele pode fazer, o que ele não pode fazer. Ou seja, ele tem um Harness ali embutido.
Eu falei. Quais são os objetivos? Eu dei.
O comportamento. Eu dei o contexto.
Eu dei. Quais são as zonas que ele pode se comportar?
Só que tem um problema.
Tudo isso é muito bonito, mas eu ainda não tenho. Quais são os critérios de saída?
Quais são os comportamentos? Eu ainda não tenho essas informações.
Então o significado.
é interessante, porque o comportamento é o seguinte. Olha.
Quando os pedidos carregarem dados que os pedidos fazem, isso.
Quando tiver sido assim. Então a ordem tem um status cancelado.
São excluídos, então o resultado é.
Colocado como nunca é endereçados como isso. E nunca colocados como Revenue.
E aí, quando o Task Spec olha só. Que legal! Quando ele entende o comportamento. Por isso que ele precisa Do Behavioral Desse Negócio Ele Vai Traduzir Isso No Evol.
O Rafa. Então você pergunta, às vezes como que os Ivaws eram gerados. Ele é baseado no comportamento no Behavioral.
Do negócio. Então ele pega aqui.
Cancelled in Revenue. E aí, o que ele faz? Ele quer um envol.
Para achar cancelled e o evolve para achar revenue dentro do modelo. Então, assim que ele faz o básico, eu tenho níveis, né?
Eu tenho nível um, nível dois, nível três na complexidade. Então, uma das formas que ele usa, ele usa o Behavioral.
Para criar o evol.
Aí você pode tanto criar.
Que você vai mostrar amanhã, como a gente cria literalmente voz, ou como a máquina cria. E você pode ter Dois Níveis Você Pode Ter O Nível Dele E O Nível Seu.
Você tem dois níveis de voz. O I voos que ele gera o Ivo que você gera no final.
E aí a gente tem como essa validação funciona, né? A decomposição desse comportamento, como ela vira um igual. E Por Que Ela Vira Um Val.
E aí o que, de fato, por exemplo, Bruno perguntou: como você conseguiu comprovar isso? Eu não entendi o que? Comprovar O Quê Mas.
Porque vejo que quando o Hardness dá o gripe Read no arquivo, eu vejo que ele geralmente lá ele full.
Como saber? Aquele sol frente provavelmente economiza Token. Sim, porque na verdade, você não tem só esses involves. Você não Tem Só Evol De Grep.
Você tem involved execution. Então a gente vai ver que são níveis. Tanto é que eles estão com cozinhas diferentes ali, né?
A gente vai ver. E outra coisa. Ele tem que bater todos esses caras para poder sair dentro dele.
Então esse é o primeiro nível que é o nível circular. Você tem um outro nível que são exatamente o Que Rafa Vai Ensinar Amanhã A Gente Vai Falar De Looping.
E a gente vai falar de voz. Então, como que você.
Pode definir os e Vols ou as características dos próximos Evol se você quiser ou não. Então ele pode gerar, Ou Você Pode Literalmente Ter Os Dois.
Então o Evol, né? Vou deixar o Rafa explicar muito mais sobre o Evol amanhã.
Mas a ideia é em que você consiga, né? E aí você tem isso no Task Spec. Ele te diz, Cara Qual O Nível.
De precisão que eu tenho desses voos que foram criados, né?
E aí ele vai te flegar. Quais são os Evals que ele tem boa confiabilidade e Vals que ele não tem.
Boa confiabilidade. E daí? A gente vai adicionar esses igual. O quê? Dentro do nosso Task Spec.
Então a gente vai vir aqui dentro do Test Spec.
Vai vir. Bdd e Volws.
E a gente vai utilizar o quê? Os critérios de validação. Então, no Behaviors.
A gente vai adicionar esse cara.
Então vamos lá dentro do arquivo.
Editar ele dentro do behavior. A gente vai adicionar qual é o comportamento dele.
No critério de sucesso, né?
A gente vai.
Adicionar.
Os Ivos.
No vale. Deixa um card.
Isso aqui é muito legal. Eu quero ver se vocês lembram disso.
O vale deixa um Card. Serve para quê?
Para fazer o bounding. Então, olha só. Que legal.
O critério de sucesso é Id vol um.
A descrição, o modelo existe, e o projeto faz o Parsing.
Ele é run. O terminal é True. E ele espera isso em vinte segundos, aproximadamente. Olha que loucura. Olha o nível.
Depois você tem o Ival dois. Descrição, pedidos cancelados aqui. Eu tenho cartões de validação que vão ser executados.
Você perguntou para mim como que eu provo, Bruno, uma das formas de provar pelo cartão de validação.
Então eu rodo Ival e o cartão que Vale do Ival. Olha que loucura, né? E eu rodo esse cartão.
E aqui eu tenho o quê? O bounding, o contrato. Olha.
Qual é a intenção, né?
O que ele vai produzir.
Quais são as ferramentas que ele vai tocar?
Qual é o time out.
Qual é a critério e assim por diante.
Boa. E aqui. Quais são as sessões de saída? O exit check.
O Brexit Check. Tem que ser o quê? Cara.
Tem que ser igual e Val dois e igual tres. Caso contrário, nada feito.
Beleza.
ótimo.
Feito. Adicionamos isso. Luan, eu preciso fazer isso na mão. Claro que não.
O Task Spec faz exatamente isso.
Beleza. Criamos esse cara.
E agora uma Spec demorou dez a quinze minutos para a gente fazer teoricamente, né?
Então a ideia é, e aqui que vem uma questão.
No backlog do dia a dia. Você tem centenas disso.
Então aí começa a vir a ideia da fábrica.
A fábrica. é exatamente isso. A fábrica é o ambiente onde você começa a receber essas informações.
E literalmente, levar essas informações e canalizar isso. Então.
Você tem um novo requisito, uma nova necessidade.
Gera. O documento decompõe as atividades, cria tarefa, e a tarefa é executada dentro de um looping.
é isso? Só que o looping.
Qual a parte? Mind Blowing? Aqui.
O loop é a própria tarefa.
A tarefa já tem tudo dentro dela.
Sacou. Ela já tem tudo.
Então, olha só. Que legal.
Olha só. Que legal!
Você tem agora começa a ficar bem interessante pra mim, que foi a parte onde eu comecei a criar meu Dark Factory Meu Dark Factory Aconteceu Justamente Dessa Forma.
Hoje. Como que funciona a Dark Factory, que funciona no cliente? Tá.
Só para vocês entenderem. E eu acho que é muito importante vocês entenderem esse thought Process.
Vocês querem entender no cliente em produção, Sim ou não?
Obviously. A galera tá acordada. Tá dormindo aí.
Então, beleza. Olha só.
Ele tem arquivos no Sftp dele.
Presta atenção. Real, tá real. Eu tô viajando. Dia vinte e nove. Agora.
Para Cleveland de novo. Para fazer um outro workshop para eles, e assim por diante.
Então eles têm um arquivinho aqui que chega, né?
Vamos. Vamos falar de uns arquivos que eu sofri bastante, que eu gosto dos que eu sofro.
Chamado Charge Back.
Charge Back. Eu quero que vocês entendam, porque se vocês não entendem o problema, vocês não entendem por que foi criado.
Então imagina que eles têm um Sftp.
E que aí tem uma empresa.
Né.
De transação financeira.
Que manda esses documentos para eles. Manda esses arquivos Txt: Enfim, para eles, né?
E aí um dos sistemas é você. Tem ali as pessoas entrando passando cartão. é um payment process system. Um sistema de pagamento.
De bordo de topo. Então eles fazem o processamento desses arquivos. Eles não são a empresa do Swipe in the Card.
Então, quando você passa o cartão na maquininha, ele não faz essa. Ele não é uma empresa que vai fazer O Quê Essa Transação Garantir Que Essa Transação Acontece.
Ela vai ser a empresa que analisa as transações e entrega essa solução de inteligência para mais de três, cem, dezassete clientes.
Ao redor do mundo. é uma empresa muito grande americana.
Beleza. Então, quando acontece esse swiping, você tem uma empresa, uma Tory Party Company.
Thirty Forty.
Que envia de tempos em tempos, no Sftp.
Esse documento. E aí vamos pegar o Charge Back que ele é bem interessante. Mudafunker.
E aí, o que. Que acontece hoje? O Charge Back sai.
Ele vai. Quem já ouviu falar nesse cara chamado.
Coloca. Vamos ver se vocês são antigos. Eu vou ver se vocês são antigos. é agora.
Alguém conhece isso aqui?
Yes Yes, o mais conhecido como Sis.
Sql server integration.
Service.
A galera até chorou aqui, né?
Beleza. E aí, o que acontece? Esse pacote pega? Deixa eu arrumar o Arrow, porque.
Eu sou arquiteto. Então, por favor. Então esse Arrow chama.
Esse cara. Isso é caso real. Tá.
Então esse cara que chama.
Uma coisa chamada. Vamos ver se vocês também sabem disso aqui. Ou se vocês já estão muito.
Muito gourmetizados que não sabem disso.
Chamam uma Sp.
Uma store procedure.
E aí a Luan? Você é mentiroso, né?
Beleza. Então aqui, ó.
Chupa chupa só para vocês entenderem.
A vida real.
Eu vou trazer um bem legal aqui pra gente ficar bem feliz. Vamos pegar aqui.
Ah, você está doido?
Ah, é fácil demais. Vamos pegar aqui. ó.
Olha que delícia essa! Procedure aqui, gente. Dá uma olhadinha.
Isso é uma procedure. Tá.
Dois mil seiscentos e oitenta. Linhas.
é pequena. Também achei bem bem suave. Tá.
E daí? Essa store procedure, chama e entrega dentro de um database.
Que é o sequcal server.
Key Ssk.
é isso?
Beleza. é basicamente isso.
E aí, a atividade simples.
Era fazer toda essa transmutação.
Para Python Aws, Lambida Databrics.
Ai que tudo.
The Good Stuff. Então, basicamente, isso tá.
E aí o que acontece? O que eu comecei a identificar. Falei: Cara.
Eu tenho são mais ou menos cem diferentes tipos de.
Documentos. Então tem charge back. Tem settlement.
The D Two fifty Six the.
Tem milhares de tipos.
Tem débito. Tem Discover. Tem downgrade. Tem.
Mdi tem Méchan.
Tem ppm. Tem vários tipos. Visa e assim por diante. Beleza.
E aí eu falei: Pô, como que é o meu processo.
Processo de corno, né? Pega, entende? O arquivo cria um Spec. Gera tal.
Faz? Interage no Spec três, cem milhões de dias.
Quebra a atividade, manda executar. Não funciona. Volta, pede para retraiar.
Valida. Bota os Gators. No começo fiz isso durante meses.
Eu falei: Cara, eu preciso porque o escopo é muito.
Muito granular. Eu vou começar a quebrar isso literalmente em micro atividades.
E daí eu comecei a gerar um backlog gigantesco de atividade. Olha que legal!
Então eu comecei a ter esses backlogs, que são as minhas atividades.
E aí eu criei um State Store que grava essa informação. Então, dentro do Task Spec, ele tem um State Dentro Do Repositório Que Ele Guarda Essas Atividades Que Ele Guarda O State Dela.
E a partir disso, você começa a ter todas as informações do que está acontecendo, do que foi feito, do Que Não Foi Feito E Assim Por Diante.
Porque o Spec ainda é muito mental.
A intenção é compilada uma vez só.
Então o que eu comecei a fazer é como que eu decomponho essas atividades como um todo, né?
E daí a gente começou a fazer o quê? Decomposição dessa atividade?
Então eu comecei a utilizar.
O nosso querido Task Spec.
Bem vindos, pirem. Boa sorte.
Então, uma vez que o Task Spec é instalado, eu posso vir aqui.
E falar. Task Speculation Version.
Eu puxei a nova versão. Agora que é três sete.
E eu posso dar um task Spec in niche.
Olha que lindo. Ele vai inicializar. Ele vai botar essas informações dentro de config, que são os templings e as Informações Do Hate Mac Assim Por Diante Que Eu Vou Ter Aqui.
Ele vai criar uma config para você.
Aqui. A gente tem algumas informações que a gente pode passar para ele.
Beleza. E olha só que coisa feia, gente. Se vocês não falarem, foda pra isso. Eu vou ficar muito triste Aí Eu Vou Ficar Pessoalmente Muito Triste Olha Só.
Como arquiteto sem executar nada, decompõe os itens cinco a oito de histórias de plano. Ou seja, eu peguei o Plano E Pedi Para Decompor.
Não escreva. Aqui vos propõe o chat único.
é o manifesto do Task Plan. Eu estou conversando em linguagem.
Cada unidade tem que ter. Ou seja, eu estou chamando e invocando o Task Spec, para poder fazer.
Então eu estou pedindo para ele decompor a atividade e criar as tarefas para mim.
é só isso. Ele entende a linguagem natural. Ele tem os Skills. Tem exatamente tudo. Então, quando você pedir para Ele Pegar Uma Tarefa E Decor.
Ou seja, pegar um plano e ver seja qualquer.
Que for, ele vai decompor o plano e vai gerar uma atividade para você.
Então ele lê o plano. Ele leu. Qual é o plano?
Então muita gente me perguntou sobre ele. Então está aqui.
Ele leu Task Plan. A estrutura do plano do Task Spec Plan é um plano.
And um, que vai apontar para uma Skill e uma estrutura.
E disso ele vai acessar o meu arquivo.
E vai propor uma atividade. Olha que loucura. Então ele propôs uma atividade para a gente aqui.
Proposto. Tá vendo?
Plano Metadado, unidade, título e esforço.
Profile. A gente developer.
Quais são os arquivos? Qual a fonte? Os porquês.
Que tem aqui. Então ele literalmente entende todo o contexto que você tem dentro do seu repositório, estrutura, documento, tudo.
E ele faz a decomposição dessa tarefa.
Beleza.
Okay, eu posso literalmente pegar esse plano.
E eu posso pedir para ele validar esse plano.
Uma chupa. Por que ele não acha o plano.
Acho que pediu para executar aqui dentro.
Talvez ele não esteja no repositório.
O que ele vai fazer. Ele vai basicamente.
Mostrar a estrutura do plan.
Que é criar o grafo, o manifesto gráfo dele. Então, aqui as atividades.
Olha que legal!
Que é exatamente isso que ele mostrou. Na verdade, no final, tá.
As atividades propostas, cada uma delas.
Beleza.
Então eu tenho aqui beleza.
Então aqui eu tenho Test Spec plan preview e o Generate. Então vamos ver se a gente consegue fazer o Preview e Generate.
Será que eu atualizei esse cara.
Aproveitason some, Batch.
O que ele não está em. Deixa eu ver se ele vai no Match.
Let's Complain. Ah, tá. Ele não está no contexto, tá? Então deixa eu pedir por aqui.
é que ele não está no contexto do Venv?
Ele está dentro dessa sessão. Aqui.
Então, basicamente, é o que eu faço. Eu faço um task plan.
Pega o manifesto que foi gerado, e peço para fazer um preview. Então ele vai mostrar aquela estrutura que eu mostrei.
E depois eu vou pedir para ele gerar.
E aí ele vai chamar pela linguagem natural. A Cieli, que tem carregado a Skill.
Vai ler esse cara e vai começar a fazer o quê? A compilar. E eu tenho cara.
A ideia.
O próprio.
O próprio Task Spec tem.
Trezentos funções, bilhões de coisas que você pode utilizar.
Então, realmente.
O que não está gerando.
Ah, cara, eu acho que é a minha instalação.
Hi. Instalação global, instalação local. Acho que está convergindo a minha instalação no repositório com a instalação global do meu Cloud Que Eu Não Especifiquei Porque Eu Instalei O Tres Sete Global E Não Instalei Ela Local.
Mas a gente vai resolver aqui. Quero que vocês vejam essas atividades sendo.
Geradas. Então ele vai criar essas atividades inteiras.
E deixa ele criar aqui.
Ele vai gerar essas atividades.
E aí ele vai gerar uma série de atividades.
Que vão ser exatamente dessa forma que a gente está vendo aqui. Então você vai ter uma série de atividades Sentadas No Seu Backlog Eu Diria Tá.
E aí, qual é a grande ideia? Você vai utilizar um looping depois, para poder executar.
Todas essas tarefas aqui.
E aí você vai ter um ciclo de ondas.
Não só isso. Ele vai entender.
Por exemplo, Task Spec. Entende quando ele vai criar o que é paralelo, o que é serial, o que pode Rodar Porque No Final Quando Ele Gera Um Plano Ele Gera Um Grafo.
Como o Rafa lá gera também. E esse grafo diz exatamente qual é a sequência que você vai utilizar. E O Que A Gente Vai Fazer.
Beleza. Então olhamos esse cara como um todo.
E aí isso me leva a.
A gente viu um pedaço, né? Então deixa ele resolver aqui do Task Spec.
E aí, antes da gente terminar. E agora eu quero dar acesso para vocês.
Vocês em primeira mão vão ter acesso à última versão do Task Spec.
Que ela foi atualizada seis horas atrás. Então tem cara. Milhões de coisas foram adicionadas aqui, muito legais. é um Tipo De Exploração Que Vocês Vão Adorar Fazer.
Tem guia. Tem tudo. Tá, eu vou abrir ele agora para vocês.
Então vou vir aqui. Change Visibility.
I want this Public.
Make this project public.
Best key.
Use Best Key.
Beleza. E aí, qual a questão? Beleza.
A gente viu Task Spec em vinte minutos. Tanto faz. Por quê?
Porque o que eu quero.
Agora é que vocês.
Entendam o conceito.
De decomposição. Tá aí, tá.
Então, qual é a minha intenção? Que vocês entendam literalmente o conceito de decomposição.
De transformar lá esse grande intenção em decomposição. Por quê? Uma vez que você entenda isso, você consegue criar.
O seu. Você consegue aprimorar. Você consegue entender o cenário como um todo.
Beleza. Então isso vira o seu processo mental.
Só que não dá pra gente aprender tudo literalmente, né?
E aqui a gente está vendo os fundamentos, os pedaços, cada um deles. E vendo manualmente como esse cara.
Realmente funciona. O boot camp.
São exatamente.
Eu diria não evolução, mas seria exatamente como você pega todos esses fundamentos.
Que a gente falou aqui. Nesses três dias. A gente vai falar amanhã de vol e de looping.
Que é o último dia onde realmente essas atividades atômicas foram geradas, como a gente, literalmente.
Executa elas constantemente. Então você tem na verdade um loop que fica recebendo atividade.
Fazendo, movendo e assim por diante.
Mas como que realmente você pega um caso? A gente pegou aqui um pedaço de um caso.
Mas como que você realmente trabalha em um caso de uso.
O que eu comecei a entender, né?
E assim como todo mundo, o código ficou barato.
Mas a confiança não.
Ou seja, se você for no mercado agora, e falar sobre Evol Engineers.
Olha só. Que legal!
Você tem hoje várias vagas no mercado sobre Evol Engineering.
Por quê? Porque uma das coisas que você quer fazer é destilar a intenção.
Inclusive tem uns cursos.
Tem uns cursos bem baratos. Tipo esse.
Eu e o Rafa que acompanho esse tipo de coisa é massa, né?
Porque a galera está pagando quatro duzentos.
E, tipo, mil pessoas. Já fizeram setecentos pessoas. Já fizeram. é bem tranquilo, tá.
Se você vier aqui em agentesc.
Engineering.
No Maven Maiden. é um lugar muito legal. Tá.
Você tem uns cursos bem legais aqui nos valores bem legais, tipo.
Esse aqui tá.
Está no bom preço. Geralmente você tem novecentos dólares. Mil dólares em dois quinhentos dólares. Enfim.
Que ensina muito do padrão de Vó. Criação multiagente.
Unidade atômica e assim por diante. Então, Evol é uma grande coisa. Intenção é uma grande coisa. O Ival é uma grande coisa.
E aí, qual o problema que vocês vão passar?
Que eu já passei. Vocês vão passar por isso. Qual é o problema?
Primeiro você começa digitando.
Depois você delega para o agente. Depois você começa a trabalhar junto.
Depois você começa a revisar o que o agente está fazendo. A maioria das pessoas ainda estão aqui.
Então as pessoas passam a revisar.
Depois você especifica.
Mas você não tem as validações.
E eventualmente você ainda está no loop fazendo calibração.
Que é pô beleza. Eu passei do Review.
Agora eu vejo o objetivo.
E agora, qual é o meu objetivo final? Eu quero somente estar.
Quando realmente.
é necessário estar. é aí, literalmente, o último nível de uma fábrica de uma Dark Factory.
Vai até um pouquinho mais. Além disso, porque ela tem uma Flywhewel.
Ela aprende com ela, né? Então ela vai pegando ali que nem o Rafa falou. No final ali dos nós. E Edias.
Você tem a parte de lessons. E daí das Lessons, você aprende.
E aí, o que realmente eu entendo, como o futuro do ensino.
Futuro do ensino mudou. Eu acho que as pessoas.
Vão cada vez mais fazer coisas assim que a gente está fazendo, mas ainda mais, Rend, mesmo realmente.
E aí, aprendendo, fazendo, falando, enfim.
Do que literalmente sentados ali assistindo gravação. Eu acredito que.
A gente tende a deixar de. De, de, de de fazer isso muito, né?
Pô. às vezes eu não consigo entrar na aula. Beleza é uma exceção, mas.
Normalmente você quer praticar junto? Você quer construir junto? Você quer literalmente fazer ver junto.
E aí a gente chama isso fora do país de Cohort.
Então o Co Rocha. Eles são.
Quantidade de pessoas limitadas dentro de uma sala.
Que eles vão passar uma semana inteira. Vão entender um caso de uso. E eles vão construir esse caso de uso.
Utilizando técnicas utilizando um bocado de coisas. Então a ideia do botiquem para exatamente essa.
Só que no Boot camp. Aqui a gente está vendo um problema.
No Butcheripe. São mais de vinte h durante uma semana. Então a gente vai fazer geralmente três a quatro horas por dia.
E aí, qual é a grande questão? A gente vai olhar para todos esses prismas aqui.
A gente vai olhar para o prisma do engenheiro de software.
A gente vai olhar para o prisma do engenheiro de dados. A gente vai olhar para o prisma do Analytics Engineer.
E a gente vai olhar para o prisma de um Devops M. Lopes.
E tudo isso vai convergir para o que a gente chama de engenharia genética. Então, no booticamp, a gente vai Ver Um Caso Real.
Que é literalmente o caso que eu trabalhei nos últimos nove meses, que é a Curve. é o mesmo tipo De Problema Só Que Com.
Com níveis ainda muito mais complexos, que vão possibilitar vocês pela primeira vez.
Fazer um treinamento que eu nunca vi no Brasil.
Primeira vez que eu estou trazendo isso é um treinamento em que você vai aprender tudo.
Você vai aprender engenharia de software. Você vai aprender engenharia de dados. Você vai aprender engenharia analítica. Você vai aprender The.
Você aprender todo o ciclo.
Você vai virar um agente. Que engenheiro? Aprendendo a fazer tudo literalmente. Tá.
Por Quê Porque Como O Rafa Falou Eu Também Acredito Muito né? E Se A Gente Olhar, Um Pouco Do futuro do que o Boris Cherny faz. Que fala, que é o criador, literalmente do Cloud Code.
Ele pensa nisso aqui, no futuro.
E aí tem uma coisa que você só vai desenvolver fazendo.
Sabe qual o nome? Taste.
Texto é uma coisa que a gente fala quando a gente usa muito llm para entender o gosto sabor.
Que é basicamente a gente fala isso quando a gente vê a llm guiando ou fazendo. Enfim.
E você começa a falar um.
Ou não.
Isso é desenvolver texto, julgamento, entendimento.
E aí a evolução é.
Você se tornar um engenheiro agêntico. Não é que você vai usar isso no próximo dia do seu trabalho.
Mas é que você vai começar a entender como você vai se comportar para as próximas vagas de trabalho ou Para A Evolução Do Mercado.
O mercado está mudando.
Gigantescamente rapidamente com vários layoffs. Então, se a gente for olhar layoff Stack.
Dois mil e vinte e seis.
Inclusive tem um site que mostra.
Eu acho que é esse.
Climata. Os Layoffs feitos.
Nesse ano. Deixa eu ver se esse Layoffs Fyi.
Tdd para humano e vai para a máquina.
Basicamente.
Precisa demorar três dias, né? Pra poder abrir.
é aqui. Tem um pouquinho de Layoffs.
Cinquenta mil. Trinta e quatro mil, catorze mil.
Vinte e quatro mil, né?
E quando a gente começa literalmente ver isso, a gente começa a entender.
Que cara. O mercado está mudando muito rapidamente.
A gente está tendo algumas flutuações, algumas coisas acontecendo de verdade no mercado.
E isso requer que nós.
Nós possamos.
Basicamente entender o que isso que esse novo significa para mim significa. Eu vou te falar. O que significa o novo para mim.
O novo significa você ser.
Multifacetado significa você ter boa Communication Skills significa você conseguir entender o que cada tribo fala. Então entender o que O Engenho De Software Fala.
Entendeu que o engenheiro fala. O que um Ai engineer fala.
Tá. é.
Então a grande ideia é você.
Entender como se posicionar nesse processo como um todo.
E aí, o que o Boris Scherney vê nos próximos anos? E aí é um cara que não dá para discutir, porque.
é o cara que inventou o Cloud Code e a vida dele ficar andando em cliente e entendendo o ambiente. é Essa A Vida Dele.
E ele vê essas cinco rolls, né? Acontecendo no mercado. Já existem Times fora do país.
Já fazendo isso.
Então você tem o Prototyper.
Que é o cara que vai pegar uma ideia e vai conseguir prototipar ela. Muito rápida.
Para ver se vai ou não vai.
Depois você tem um builder que ele vai tornar aquele protótipo em Production.
Ou seja, ele vai ter que entender, cara. O Prototype é o cara que vai ter que entender muita coisa, Né O Builder Também.
Ele vai descer uma camada abaixo.
Depois você tem o sweíper, que é o cara que vai simplificar.
Que vai otimizar, que vai literalmente fazer com que o processo fique.
Mais interessante. Depois você tem o Grower.
Que é o cara que vai inteirar constantemente em cima da fábrica e fazer com que o processo entre.
Nos trilhos e fique constante.
E depois você tem o Mantiller.
Que é o cara que vai manter essa informação.
E no booticamp. Você vai aprender cada roll dessa.
Você vai prototipar.
Você vai construir.
Você vai orquestrar.
Você vai criar factory.
E você vai manter posteriormente com grafos.
Então, na verdade, a gente vai ver todos os anéis. Só que esses anéis vão ser feitos no caso de Uso Mesmo Do Dia Um.
A o dia. Sim, a gente vai começar com o problema e terminar com a solução. Deus vai ver tudo.
Ah, então já pegar o problema, entender o problema.
E daí a gente vai utilizar, em vez de fazer na mão, a gente vai utilizar técnicas.
Então a gente vai utilizar.
A gente vai utilizar.
Desk Spec. A gente vai utilizar Simwise para dividir o sistema. A gente vai automatizar a fábrica.
A gente vai utilizar linear. A gente vai utilizar toda uma stack.
Para construir isso. E isso é canônico, porque você pode usar em qualquer lugar.
Então, como que é basicamente o ambiente que a gente vai passar.
Uma plataforma de pagamento.
Que tem alguns probleminhas interessantes que vão chocar vocês primeiro.
Arquivos no Sftp.
Segundo regras de negócio entre o arquivo e a Store procedure em Java.
Lua. Eu nem sei o que é Java.
é exatamente isso que eu quero.
Cara. Não conheço muito Stop City. Beleza, vai ter Stop City embedada.
E vai ter literalmente uma prova de como essa informação significa. Então a gente está entrando num sistema.
Que, primeiramente, vocês vão ver muito nos próximos anos.
Que é fazer o quê? Modernização, mover de um lado para o outro, modernizar algo mais legado para algo mais moderno.
Então esse é um projeto.
Que ele é muito atual hoje.
é pegar qualquer problema antigo e refactorar ele para um momento novo, para uma nova plataforma.
E aí, no legado, a gente tem como eu falei para vocês, né? Sftp.
Java Core com as regras de negócio enterradas lá dentro.
A gente tem store. Procedures com lógicas complexas.
A gente tem informações manuais de trabalho que a galera faz. Em cinco noites, a gente vai transformar tudo isso Em Um Ambiente Moderno.
A gente vai fazer ingestão, processamento, Pi. Ai, ai. A gente vai fazer bronze. Silver e Gold.
A gente vai fazer transformação do código Java.
A gente vai trabalhar com todas as vertentes. A gente vai fazer fast Api e Mcp.
A gente vai criar Golden Match. Vai ter Golden Match e vai fazer. E Vols.
A gente vai entender. Esse Walls.
E a gente vai conseguir garantir uma das coisas que exatamente.
Are Ground Truth, que é ter o ambiente do que significa. E uma coisa que eu achei mais foda de todas.
A gente vai conseguir identificar um problema.
Que o agente identificou.
Que é um problema no legado.
Então a gente vai conseguir pelo Flywheel. Pelas memórias que a gente vai.
A gente vai conseguir identificar isso.
Já passar por uma fábrica de intenção.
Spec Hardness. A gente evol aceita e a gente vai criar uma Flywheel para isso.
E aí, o que é legal, do jeito que eu dividi esse workshop.
Só para deixar claro, esse. Esse.
Não é workshop nesse boot camp.
You know sempre que vai ser vendido.
Tá? é por aproximadamente dois mil dólares no meio. Vem só para avisar para vocês, tá.
Que a gente já tem, na verdade, pessoas que querem ele, inclusive a empresa da Curve, que eu trabalho. São Dez Pessoas Que Vão.
Participar disso junto com outras pessoas. Então esse mesmo treinamento vai valer dois mil dólares em inglês.
Só para vocês entenderem. Por quê? Porque não existe isso no mercado. E a gente está trazendo realmente de forma.
Prioritário para vocês. Como sempre.
Então, o que que a gente tem nas cinco noites, tá? Primeira noite.
Você vai se comportar literalmente como um arqueologista.
A ideia aqui é você entender o problema.
No segundo dia, a gente vai traduzir. Então a gente vai se comportar mais com dinheiro de software.
No terceiro dia, a gente vai construir.
Que vai ser literalmente ser um engenheiro de dados. Um ai Engineer.
No quarto dia, a gente vai orquestrar por ir, Vals e assim por diante.
E no último, a gente vai fazer a fábrica. Então, em cada dia.
A gente vai utilizar um arquétipo e a gente vai utilizar um roll.
Então imagina que no primeiro dia você vai vestir.
Aqui o Hatzinho. E vai comportar como Solutions Architect para entender o problema.
Depois como tradutor, você vai entrar como desenvolvedor de software. Vai prender design pattern de engenharia, software.
Vai entender. Programação básica de programação. Vai aprender o código de Java por via gêntica. Vai entender.
Alô. Mas eu não sei nada de Java. Eu também não sei. Mas a gente vai entender. é isso.
Que é a questão da mentalidade do Engineer. é exatamente isso.
é você entender o problema.
Depois a gente reconstruir como engenheiro de dados.
Depois a gente vai utilizar a parte de validação com a Engineer e a gente vai terminar criando a roda como um todo.
O que vocês vão ter, tá.
Vocês vão ter o que vocês vão ganhar. O que a gente vai.
Deixar com vocês.
A gente vai para cada dia. A gente vai trabalhar com umas coisas interessantes. Por exemplo, eu vou mostrar para Vocês Como Que Eu Crio O Second Brain.
Do projeto. E como que eu alimento ele para retroalimentar toda a inteligência que eu tenho dentro do projeto.
A gente vai dar acesso para vocês. Eu e o Rafa vamos dar acesso para vocês do Ontoleia.
Luan. O que é um toleia só para quem está na linha do Bushimp. Tá.
Want to Layer. é o produto open source que o Rafa desenvolveu.
Que faz ontologia inteira do projeto.
Ou seja, lembra que a gente falou da ontologia. Então imagine que você já tem um projeto criado que você conecta a fonte.
E aí você literalmente extrai a ontologia inteira dessa informação que a gente vai usar para conseguir literalmente tirar a ideia desse cara.
Are you? Tu vai ver Harness e Task Spec.
A gente vai ver looping. A gente vai se comportar como produto de dados. Então a gente vai registrar atividades. Vai Verificá Las Andando.
Entre o negócio e a gente vai processar.
Não faio eu. Então imagina que você vai ter requisitos chegando. E você vai ver uma fábrica literalmente funcionando, pegando a intenção, compilando.
Passando e sobe com a fase mais legal.
Quando você entende esse processo, você cria isso de forma unattended.
Então, o que acontece quando cai a requisição.
Você tem um acionamento, um loop que aciona.
E como ele já sabe a intenção. Ele já fez isso várias vezes. Ele já aprendeu. Ele não precisa de Você Então Ele Continua Rodando Ele Descobre Especifica Constrói.
Testa valida e entrega.
Bem, eu acredito muito que o que vocês vão aprender aqui vai literalmente colocar vocês no próximo passo. Me colocou No Próximo Passo Então Vocês Na Verdade Vão Pegar Tudo Do Que Eu Fiz Nos últimos Nove Meses.
Vai estar tudo compilado.
Aqui tá.
E hoje, para vocês.
Vai sair por Rmil e quatro noventa e sete.
O valor que vai sair no dia do lançamento é de R um. Então vocês têm quinhentos de desconto.
Por estar na semana da Engenharia Agêntica.
O que vocês vão levar com isso? Vocês vão ter o saco. Onde vem.
Who Want to Lay hoje Spec, que já está disponível. O Test Spec. Mas aí vem a parte legal. Vocês Vão Ter Acesso Ao Sim Wise.
Ou seja, vocês vão ter acesso a engines que eu utilizo para cortar.
Para fazer toda a descoberta da intenção. Corte do dado.
Geração da tarefa para a gente poder construir a máquina. E isso aqui para você é canônico. Então você vai Conseguir Utilizar O Task Spec.
E o. Sim Wise, tá.
Então os dois. Beleza.
Bem, a gente vai praticar todas essas rolls em cinco dias. Então, treinamento denso é um treinamento em que você Vai Estar Construindo Comigo Então Quais São Os Requisitos.
O requisito é um só. Tem uma Lln.
Um plano do Codex, que é o mais generoso, geralmente, ou o Cloud Code ou um Deep Psic.
Vai funcionar muito bem, porque é multi rara. Então vocês vão construir juntamente comigo no dia a dia. A gente Vai Construir O Primeiro Dia.
Segundo dia, terceiro dia. A gente vai junto construindo isso. é a ideia do cohort.
Para que vocês possam aplicar juntamente comigo. Tá.
A gente vai ter aproximadamente de segunda a sexta. Eu julgo que, no mínimo quatro horas. A gente vai começar.
Oito. Termina onze e meia meia noite todo dia, tá.
Geralmente os boot camps vão até meia noite. às vezes até um pouquinho mais do que meia noite.
Bem, o que eu posso falar, cara, eu.
Eu acho que eu tenho um conhecimento legal pra passar para vocês. A gente viu um pedacinho na semana.
Vocês vão ver literalmente que eu estou.
Utilizando lá no Frontier, o Rafa vai estar comigo também no Boot Camp. Então vocês vão ver umas coisas bem legais.
Se eu conseguir consumir todo esse insumo dessas informações.
E eu deixei um presentinho para quem está aqui, que a gente estava pensando, cara, qual seria um presentinho legal pra quem.
Adquiri até meia noite de hoje, que eu acho que é interessante para quem literalmente se compromete.
A gente já tem aproximadamente, tá? São dois, cem vagas, aproximadamente. A gente tem. Acho que já mais cem, vinte Pessoas Antes Mesmo Do Lançamento.
Então já tem pessoas que já compraram antes lá na Live do Youtube.
No pré lançamento. E agora a gente está trazendo antes de lançar no dia vinte e quatro.
Eu vou deixar só para quem tá lá? Tá? Pra quem adquirir, vai ter acesso eterno ao Taskexpect.
Eterno. Então eu trabalho com o Test Spec há cinco meses. Então eu estou evoluindo com ele constantemente.
Vocês não têm acesso eterno, ou Sim, mais.
Porque eu vou dar acesso ao Github lá para vocês, ele vai ser fechado e vocês vão ter acesso.
E eu trabalho. Test Spec. Sim, Wise.
Vocês vão ter acesso.
Três sessões do nosso programa de datachip.
Datasip é o meu programa anual de mentoria.
Quem aqui é datasip galera. São trinta pessoas que são escolhidas entre trinta a quarenta pessoas por ano, que são Escolhidas Para Participar Da Minha Mentoria.
A gente passa um ano. E aí vocês vão ter a oportunidade de viver.
A mentoria. Eu vou passar três workshops. Falando de task Specs in wise e converse, você vai ganhar.
E aí? Ainda tem uma sessão extra. Eu vou trazer o Warner. Chaves da Piffin, que é o Solutions Architect.
Para poder vir falar de agêntica para vocês. Só pra vocês terem ideia. A hora desse cara, ele custa aproximadamente Quinhentos Seiscentos Dólares A Hora.
Ele vai estar lá dentro de uma sessão nossa do Datasip.
Falando sobre isso, tá?
Então, cara, eu acho que tem tudo para vocês. Vão ter acesso ao Task Spec. Sim, Wise. Vão ter três sessões.
Três sessões sobre cada um desses pontos, mas.
Esse evento com Warner.
Onde a gente vai fazer podcast, falar com ele, perguntar.
Várias outras coisas. Vou trazer umas coisas muito legais para ele.
Eu acho. Aqui você tem tudo pelo valor de Rmil e quatro noventa e sete. Tá.
Então eu vou deixar o Link aqui para vocês.
Lembrando que é First Come First Served.
Tá? Deixa eu só para não passar o cupom.
Calma. Ver se tá tudo certo.
Acho que teve algum problema no Cupom.
Enviado. Deixa eu ver. Aqui.
Se é esse.
Time deu algum problema no Cupom.
Ah, off quente. Deixa eu ver aqui se eu tenho.
Beleza.
Então, ó o cupom.
Tem o Off quinhentos. Tá pra vocês pagarem por R quatro.
Eu não sei porque que ele não colocou o Cupom.
Que estranho. Deixa eu ver aqui. Ah, tá. Calma aí.
Que é isso? Deixa eu ver. Beleza. é isso. Boa aqui. Desculpa.
Beleza antes da gente voltar.
Para a nossa aula. Ficou alguma dúvida do Buticamp? Inclusive vou usar esses dez minutos para vocês tirarem. Vai ter Isso Vai Fazer Isso Que Eu Acho Que Tem às Vezes Dúvida.
Tem alguma dúvida?
André.
Antes de você responder. Quem é da formação.
Tem acesso.
Quem é? Da formação de Ai de Engineering. Tem acesso ao boot camp.
Wow, você tem, mais ou, menos a previsão assim de quanto que a gente vai gastar de tokens mais ou, menos para ver quanto que, eu vou deixar aqui no cofrinha aqui para gastar nas llms e outro detalhe provavelmente na sexta.
Talvez eu não consiga, participar porque eu, vou estar viajando e vai ser aniversário da minha filha vai ser gravado como que vai ser.
Beleza em relação a Token? Não, não tenho uma ideia de Token, mas.
Eu acho que em torno de vinte. Se você guardar ali para para dentro do open router, você consiga fazer.
Eu sugeriria uma assinatura do Códex. Talvez uma básica.
Porque eu acho que ela vai funcionar muito bem.
Em relação à gravação? Sim, vai ser gravado e vocês vão ter acesso à gravação. Quem.
Adquirir, tá? Então vocês vão ter acesso a uma plataforma de gravação.
You won my pie é o pai né só, que com um plus a mais não é isso.
Isso.
Ah bacana então eu consigo usar ele no, lugar do cláudio né.
Consegue facilmente tranquilamente.
Estou empolgado.
Bye bye.
Porque com ele com o pai eu consigo rodar meus hardness, local também o meu velho local também.
Exatamente exatamente.
Já vou colocar uma paz e já começar a brincar aqui.
é isso aí. Bom demais.
Carol.
Ah, I think. Acho que eu mandei um note aí para você.
Esse, ano, estava conseguindo desmontar luan deixa eu te perguntar eu consigo ver os conteúdos desse budcamp, porque aqui já pega no link de pagamento né que mandaram aí e também queria saber.
Esse desconto é só disponível até hoje meia noite.
Eu acho que o desconto. Eu acho que até dia dezoito, eu acho, tá, a questão é a questão da quantidade de pessoas no Cohort que a gente não aceita. A Gente Tem Um número Limitado Porque eu não Consigo.
Okay.
Por exemplo, ter quinhentos pessoas no cohorte. Eu não consigo. Então tem um limite de vagas. Então acho que até Dia Dezoito Se Eu Não Me Engano.
Aí. Você não vai ter os bônus lá.
Mas se você tiver que pensar sobre isso, ou tiver que fazer alguma organização.
Eu acho melhor você falar com um time.
Com o time de vendas. Mas eu acho que até dia dezoito, se eu não me engano.
Esse valor que depois ele sobe. O lote.
E aí ele, começaria dia vinte e quatro desse mês é isso né.
Boa pergunta. Deixa eu confirmar.
Eu só estou vendo aqui na minha agenda. é do dia vinte e quatro ao dia vinte e oito.
é isso mesmo. De oito.
Meia noite.
Wilker só quer paz. Fala aí, meu querido.
O que tu me diz?
Will quer paz grande luan.
Boa desde quando eu te conheci lá com a formação de. Spark data brics enfim acho que o meu trabalho que tem me motivado.
Direcionar essas formações enfim e eu vejo no ambiente sabe, contextual no ambiente de trabalho em geral as pessoas usam copart, que é o pessoal usa aqui. Mas. A nossa área tem, acesso por exemplo ao data, brics.
E eu queria eu vi você falar muito das zlm, comparando entre, elas e se você puder falar, qual, é a sua percepção o que você tem visto no mercado os comentários das pessoas falarem sobre o jean e coach não sei se tem foge, um pouco do assunto aqui.
Não foge um pouco do assunto? Não, a gente vai ter. é porque muita coisa acontecendo ao mesmo tempo. Mas Você Vai Receber Uma Comunicação Semana Que Vem.
A gente vai ter isso aqui. Para quem é da formação? Só para quem é da formação.
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo mostrar aqui.
Vocês vão ter um treinamento de A para Databriks.
Sure.
Então acho que antes de eu responder isso, é melhor.
Do, ya respondeu.
Vocês na verdade navegaram. é exatamente. Vocês vão ter. Jean. Vão ter tudo dentro. Então, quem faz parte da formação de Spark.
Vai ter esse workshop disponível lá. Que eu vou apresentar. Sobre como criar toda a parte agêntica de desenvolvimento. Github Gin Code Onde Catalogue.
Todas as novas features de Lake Flow.
Vai estar tudo lá. Agent Skills, que já está embedado. Então, como criar a plataforma inteira? Infraestrutura inteira.
Então, para quem é.
O Will agora está em paz. Exatamente, tá.
Will tem paz agora.
Então você vai receber isso aqui, tá? Fica tranquilo.
Show obrigado.
Fala aí, Felipe.
Eu estou bem.
Tudo bem mestre luan para quem está assim começando nesse universo trabalha com já com produtos digitais mas já consegue fazer algumas coisas assim mas está em uma, fase mais inicial.
Você recomendaria qual dos seus, cursos para, poder chegar no nível de, também estar nesse nível que a gente está aí na parte argêntica.
Para começar para iniciar realmente aí, com você aprendendo o básico começar por exemplo o curso de engenharia ali de arte é um bom caminho para a gente, poder começar o que você sugere.
Cara. Se você quer começar, eu sugeriria fazer a formação.
Por quê? Você pode fazer vários cursos soltos. Se você vai chegar teoricamente no mesmo objetivo, vai demorar mais. Obviamente.
Mas por que eu acho legal? A formação.
Porque, primeiro a formação, você já vai ter acesso ao Budicamp. Você já vai ter acesso a esse conteúdo.
E dentro da formação, você tem setenta horas de conteúdo.
Então, dessas setenta horas, você tem aproximadamente dez, doze horas só de fundamento.
Então assim você vai aprender.
Tudo que a gente falou aqui, lá no detalhe lá embaixo. Então vai ser uma parada, que é uma formação Que Você Vai Gastar Tres Quatro Meses Ali.
Nos fundamentos. Dois meses, talvez fundamento. Mas você vai ter uma solidez muito grande. Então, do jeito que a formação é estruturada.
Você tem ali a parte zero que é literalmente a nossa explicação do que é ser um Ai Native Engineer. Depois Você Tem A Parte De Fundamentos.
Depois você tem a parte de workshops que é sobre as tecnologias.
Depois você tem a parte dos boot camps. Então não é um boot camp. Só então tem um boot camp De Cloud Tem De Codax Que Vai Ser Lançado Mês Que Vem.
Tem esse. Agora vai ter um de Hermes Agents. Então vai ter todos os tempos das tecnologias mais utilizadas.
E você vai aprender a construir tudo isso no booticamp. Então tem tudo.
Então, se eu fosse escolher algo para ter tudo num lugar atualizado.
Eu escolheria formação. Eu acho que ela vai te trazer todo o conteúdo. Sinceramente.
Pode negociar Diego com um time comercial. Eles resolvem isso com você. Pode estar tranquilo.
Mais alguma dúvida? Podemos seguir.
Então todo mundo pegou o Task Spec.
Vou deixar o Link aqui de novo, porque daqui a pouco eu fecho ele. Então, quem pegou, pegou quem não pegou.
Não pega mais.
Só para quem tiver na formação.
Ou tiver, né? No Budcamp.
Beleza.
Vamos voltar.
Então, a gente. Vamos ver.
Foi resolvido. Então vamos lá. Olha lá! Que legal.
Vamos ver qual foi o problema. Acho que deve ter sido a minha instalação global.
é o meu problema de instalação que estava dando antes. Acho que ele deve ter consertado aqui.
Então era só. Que legal. Vamos dar uma olhada nas tarefas que foram criadas.
Então vamos abrir aqui. ó.
Agora é a parte que o pai ou a criança chora e o pai não vê. Olha só. Que delícia.
Koldesk Spec gerou o tipo de esforço budget tipo de agente, o que depende o que ele vai tocar.
Tem várias outras coisas aqui que não são colocadas por padrão. Você pode mexer em várias opções. Prioridade Tag.
Referência. Enfim, aí a gente tem aqui o porquê.
O objetivo, contexto, o comportamento, o critério de sucesso, o cartão de validação.
O cheque de validação.
O que não tocar e tudo isso para as atividades.
E está vendo aqui o pleno. O plano foi gelado também. Ele conseguiu gerar o plano aqui.
Tá vendo? E olha só. Ele gerou State Demo. Olha só. Que coisa linda gente. Eu tenho o estado das atividades.
Então, quais estão em Queue.
Quais estão em progresso. Coisa linda, né?
é.
Quais são as Tasks? Quais são os esquemas, então? Tenho todas as informações aqui.
A gente tem tarefa. M também. ó.
M, que é média.
Então aqui você já tem algumas outras complicações em relação ao que você vai fazer.
Vamos ver se eu acho uma outra que é média. Não deve ter uma large aqui.
Só esse e medium Small e medium.
Beleza. Essas são as atividades especificações. Enfim, agora eu quero mostrar para vocês.
Como que a gente vai fazer o bounding disso, né?
Então, agora a gente tem um, dois, três, quatro, cinco, seis pacotes, né? A gente tem seis pacotes.
A gente vai ter a composição deles.
Porque agora a gente vai criar um grafo de relação.
Tu acredita que ele faz isso. Sim, ele faz.
Então o Task Spec. Ele faz um grafo de relação.
Do que é.
As tarefas do que significa.
E, principalmente, da relação entre elas, se elas podem ser executadas.
Se elas podem ser paralelas. Se elas são seriais, se elas dependem de alguma coisa, deixa eu ver se eu consigo achar.
Aqui. ó Caraca, isso é lindo, né? Ele tem no front matter. Essa informação.
Então, depends on. Depende da Stgd. Capture payments.
Que é esse cara que depende da Raw Payment source.
E ela não depende de ninguém. Loucura, né? Então ele vai criar um grafo para mim.
Sobre isso que vai ser executado.
Tá.
Vamos dar uma olhadinha. Vamos pegar aqui o Ready Set.
A gente vai vir aqui no quatro.
A gente decompôs cinco.
Right. A gente vai continuar.
E basicamente, a partir da Task State, produz uma tabela com, no máximo, oito linhas de pacote Depends. Enfim.
Ordene ela pelo grafo.
Que basicamente já foi feito, né? Eu estou pedindo literalmente para ele predizer um pouquinho do que vai acontecer. Eu Quero Que Ele Mostre Pra Gente Como Que Vai Ser.
Então vou botar aqui.
Desk Spec.
Execution. O cara como eu amo.
Ou isso que facilitou a minha vida.
Principalmente quando vocês entrarem no internos de entender o Task Spectrum tem toda uma sessão ou fazer uma sessão de Três Horas Só Sobre Task Spec.
Todos os detalhes nuances e assim por diante.
E aí, ó, uma vez que ele verifique as atividades, quais são as referências, enfim, que já tem lá no front, meter.
Eu vou verificar.
Se essas atividades estão prontas.
E se eu posso fazer um link nelas, Linch, é verificar se elas estão realmente organizadas, estruturadas. Se tem algum Tipo De Problema Nessas Atividades.
Então deixa eu ver. Agora se ele conseguiu consertar esse cara.
Beleza. Olha só. Que legal. Eu usei um Task Spec Ready.
Então ele tem duas tarefas aqui que estão aparecendo como prontas? Porque não existe nenhuma relação.
Quatro, Red Specs, Hidden, Blocked by unmatch depends on. Olha que delícia!
Então aqui ele fala. Então, basicamente, só para vocês entenderem, a lógica do rolê é, você tem um sistema agêntico Que Chamam A Cieli.
Que tem Skills vinculadas. Então é assim que a gente faz.
Então você transforma o processo em um processo determinístico.
Então, se eu vou dar um Task Spec.
Ele vai tentar verificar se existe algum tipo de problema.
Está tudo ok, o linking. Então as atividades estão bonitonas lá estruturadas. Tudo ok com elas.
A gente tem as dependências, ó.
Que eu mostrei. ó, tá vendo?
E a gente fez literalmente.
O bounding, e realmente deixar elas.
é vinculadas e endereçadas.
Sabe qual a parte mais linda? A gente não decidiu a ordem.
Quem decidiu foi o gráfico. Beleza.
Agora a gente vai literalmente executar essas atividades.
Então a gente vai inteirar em cima delas, e a gente vai ver exatamente como a gente vai fazer isso. Tá.
Então a gente vai partir de um contexto completamente Fresh.
Com os arquivos em memória.
E a gente vai executar uma atividade como um todo.
Então a gente vai vir aqui.
E vai pedir para essas atividades serem executadas. E elas vão ter vários Shapes. Se elas vão ser executadas com Sucesso Se Elas Não Vão Ser Executadas Com Sucesso.
Qual é a parte de stopping? Qual é o critério de chegada?
E a parte mais legal que vocês vão ver.
Que eu acho que vai explodir a mente de vocês.
é.
It's hick. é a prova do que eu venho falando há três dias.
Uma Spec três diferentes Harness executando ela. Vamos dar uma olhada.
Então vamos dar uma olhadinha nele. Aqui.
Chegar aqui no seis.
Execute One though. A ideia abriu uma nova sessão.
Que a gente vai literalmente pedir para executar. Você é o Developer definido no Agents.
Leia task e execute exatamente o pacote. Construa apenas dentro do Models. Ao terminar, Rod Exact, não leia nenhum outro arquivo de plano.
E tal. Agora construa March de Revenue do item dez.
Depois.
Deixa eu ver como ele fez aqui.
Tá? Eu quero fazer melhor do que.
Eu quero mostrar uma coisa mais legal. ó.
Vou mostrar uma coisa legal pra vocês. Aqui.
A gente vai abrir um Work Tree.
Deixa eu ver se esse. Ah. Calma aí.
Just a second.
Hold your horses. Eu vou.
Comitar esse cara no Rapp.
Porque eu geri as tarefas. Então eu estou comitando ele no repositório.
E agora vou mostrar uma coisa. Muito, muito, muito, muito, muito, muito foda.
é um comitê beleza aí. Agora, olha só o que eu vou fazer.
Eu vou vir aqui e vou criar uma Work Tree.
Totalmente separada. Vou chamar ela de.
Work Tree.
Cc.
Task.
Beleza. O que é Ccc.
é uma Orct Trade Cloud Code.
The. Vou chamar o Cloud. Vou chamar o Opus e vou colocar aqui. Você é o desenvolvedor do Agents. Leia a tarefa.
Task dele, Gross Audrey, execute exatamente o que o pacote numera.
Beleza. Vou fazer isso aqui.
Agora eu vou.
Vim aqui.
Vou criar uma outra Work Tree.
E vou falar.
Grock Grock. Não vamos pegar aqui o Codec.
E eu vou pedir para o agora.
O Luna.
Max com fast mode.
Executar essa tarefa.
E agora eu vou.
Pegar.
Esse cara.
Vou agora.
Pedir para o.
Gypsick.
Eu vou copiar.
Vou selecionar o All My Pie.
Vou selecionar o Deep Sick Flash quatro.
Vou selecionar ele em Max.
Vou colocar ele em oulo Mode.
Vou fazer.
Eu acho que vocês nunca viram isso aqui. Alguém já viu isso aqui?
Eu. Dá uma atividade.
Em três Indianes, completamente sem contextos, porque elas vão.
A informação agora são completamente diferentes.
Isso, teremos um resultado triplicado. Exatamente porque o que eu quero mostrar para vocês é que.
Será que, independentemente do Llm, ele consegue desempenhar a tarefa.
Como um todo.
E aí?
é isso?
Vamos ver.
Porque se ele fizer aí, é uma parada meio de tiro na cabeça.
Porque a gente está falando que toda essa ideia que a gente construiu.
Ela faz muito sentido, porque você pode utilizar o modelo local. Você pode utilizar modelos.
E eu fiz questão de utilizar aqui, por exemplo, Luna.
Que é um modelo mais inferior.
Eu fiz questão de utilizar um Deep Psic Flash aqui.
E eu utilizei o Cloud Code.
Clouds Cold just click fill.
No Deep Tomorrow's.
Dbt models.
Staging stg Daily Grows, ordered.
Beleza tá aqui.
Essa foi aquela que ele escreveu.
Ele fala também que o modelo D da referência, onde acha cancelado.
Faz o Rename faz o casting.
Das coisas que eu corrigi, os evol.
Blah, blah, blah. E aí? Aqui a gente tem essa tarefa.
Beleza. Então ele escreveu aqui.
O Work Tree é uma cópia do repositório inteira que é rodada de forma completamente isolada.
Então é como se você estivesse copiando o repositório inteiro.
Num outro ambiente, para ter um ambiente completamente isolado.
Do repositório. Mesmo.
Isso. A gente faz muito para sistemas agênticos. Por quê? Porque quando você cria Brents.
Quando você cria branches, o que acontece quando você tem uma Branch? Você tem vários agentes trabalhando.
às vezes eles trocam branches entre eles. Então o agente se perde.
Quando você criou arctês, você dá espaços completamente separados para eles trabalharem.
Então aqui, ó, ele criou também. Dbt.
Models Staging.
Daily Gross.
Que loucura, cara. Parece igual, né?
Pirei. Você está doido? é pira demais.
Você vendo Dbt aqui de novo.
Stage.
All codecs.
Agora, a parte mais legal de todas.
Eu vou pegar o do codec.
Esse aqui é Cloud Code.
Esse aqui é Codex.
Esse aqui é de Psic Flash que não custou nada.
Gbc, Key.
Vamos ver. Vamos ver se o nosso orquestrador. Ele.
Ele de fato concorda nesse cara.
Então posso excluir aqui esse Work Tree.
Posso conhecer Work Tree.
Pós conhecer Work Tree.
Basicamente, eu pedi para ele revisar o que cada um fez.
Da atividade que a gente tinha pedido só para a gente ver.
E aí a gente entendeu que existe uma Flywhewel, né?
Você ainda está digitando de falar aqui? é, mas eu estou digitando.
A gente está criando uma Flywheel. No primeiro dia, a gente aprendeu a especificação Prompt com texto. Segundo dia, a Gente Entendeu Hardness Controle.
E bounded. Dia três. A gente entendeu. Execução quebral ali. Desenvolver o espectro.
Terminar ela em tarefas.
E amanhã a gente vai ver em profundo. E vai ver o looping acontecendo, girando em profundidade.
Para que a gente possa entregar o Result.
Então a gente faz o trabalho.
A evidência suporta o que a gente precisa. O humano continua decidindo.
E a gente tem que literalmente decidir o que é legítimo e o que não é.
Beleza.
E aí, o que vocês acharam faz sentido.
Muito doido.
Muito doido ou não? Muito doido. Muito doido, né?
Bem, agora que a loucura foi generalizada.
Vamos abrir para perguntas, né?
Quais perguntas temos para hoje.
A desculpa. Deixa eu só mostrar uma coisa para vocês falarem, foda, eu esqueci de mostrar. Esqueci. Calma aí.
Vamos ver quantas fodas a gente tem agora. Eu pedi para uma sessão sem contexto validar. Tá.
Só para vocês entenderem um pouquinho.
Ninguém errou. Todas as três passaram com Gate. Isso aqui é um machado. Não é um comprimento. Não é uma Satisfação Então O Cloud Code Passou No Valor.
O Gypsy que passou e o Códex passou.
Três diferentes Vals que eles nunca tinham vistos. E eles conseguiram chegar no mesmo resultado.
Aí a gente fala só uma coisa assim, né?
Hashtag chupa.
Mundo.
Further then. Ah, eu sei. Isso é fod.
Ou seja, a gente está tentando ver evol validações.
Olha só. Que legal!
O County importa muito mais que parece aspecto que esse citado, tal tal tal tal tal dois números, o label Blá Blá Blá Codecs.
Foi o mais fraco no limite de tal requisito. Não sei o que mais completou. Também.
O Gypsy que fez o claim e tal, mas chegou no mesmo resultado.
E a gente completou a atividade estampada. Como a Provet.
E aí, cara? O resto é história. Vocês.
Testarem, validarem, ver o ambiente de vocês, entender.
Aqui. Eu estou utilizando ele no modo piloto, né? Então, assim.
Aqui. Eu não especifiquei milhões de coisas que eu posso especificar. Eu tenho escritos que fazem. Tem de dificuldade. Então Você Vai Navegar Dentro Do Task Spec.
E você vai entender literalmente o que é? Tá.
Vamos lá, Sebastião!
Boa noite luan boa noite rafael boa noite a todo mundo.
Boa noite.
Cá!
Rua eu comecei a fazer um pouco do meu harness, baseado no nosso workshop tres da formação você começou a, mostrar para a gente a intenção a estrutura decomposição e eu tive muita dor.
Seeing. Hmm.
Pra fazer. Essa decomposição que foi? Feita ali e hoje começou a ficar essa semana está começando a ficar muito claro que a decomposição ali no workshop já estava feita com sim feito já quebrada as coisas esses estalos começou a aparecer, para mim.
E uma das minhas principais dores ainda não está clara.
The que como resolver eu queria trazer aqui como pergunta que.
Hoje eu estou utilizando já a gente? Pré construídos de maneira global mas a gente já tem visto que a gente até constrói esses agentes baseados a gente viu até aqui nessa semana que foi mostrado que a gente cria os agentes baseados em arquitetos.
Desenvolvedores e reviewers.
Como é, que eu levo essa estrutura de construção de agente baseado no, meu projeto local já pensando até em deploy em flychecks criando hoje, os evals você já até citou que é muito faça local garanta que funcione o local.
Mas. A parte de levar para a produção muitas vezes algumas coisas, acabam quebrando então, isso tem sido uma bastante uma dor bem grande linha porque acaba mudando a arquitetura e tendo outros processos como é que a gente leva essa estrutura a nível produtiva.
Acho que é nesse caminho.
é? Eu acho que sim. O que vai ajudar você a ter literalmente um framework para poder cortar, certo? E Dividir As Atividades Achar As Relações E Aí Pensa Isso Acontecendo.
No deve para você sair disso. Para a produção que você tem que garantir é.
Literalmente testar o seu ambiente como um todo. Por exemplo.
Verificar quais são os Alelez que se comportam bem em certas atividades. E daí que você tem essas atividades sendo Executadas E Que Você Valide As E Tenha Certeza Que Está Funcionando.
O próximo passo daí.
é você criar esse processo de separação de Deployment de Dev para Prod. Como você vai fazer isso aí? Vai depender.
No meio.
Do ambiente da stake que você tem, né? Vai depender da stake do ambiente que você tem.
Mas é uma das coisas lá no botiquim. Porque você vai aprender que pô. Eu vou me comportar como um Devops agora.
Então você vestindo Sebastião ou vestindo Hat lá de vamos supor. Engenheiro de dados terminou a infraestrutura inteira.
Chegou para o cara de Devolve e falou: cara de Devops. é o seguinte.
Tem infraestrutura inteira. Aqui está funcionada. Eu tenho um pre*flight check de desenvolvimento valida, bonitinho. Tá tudo certo.
Como que eu faço para passar para a produção. E daí? A gente vai começar a aprender.
Várias coisas relacionadas ao ciclo de vida de Devops.
Como que você constrói? Como que você garante estado.
Como que você move de deve para prod de forma incremental. Então tudo isso, você vai aprender.
Quando você vestiu o Hatch de Devops, é porque você ainda não vestiu esse Hatch de Devops pra ver quais São Todas As Possibilidades Que A Gente Está Vendo.
Mas são várias que dá para garantir que não está dentro do realm da engenharia. Ela está dentro do Realm de Devops.
Então, se hoje, no seu dia a dia, se você quiser depois abrir a lenda e falar. Cara, eu fiz Isso Isso, E Isso.
Agora eu quero pensar no ciclo de deve para Prod. Olhando com a visão de Devop, você vai começar a Ver Que Ele Vai.
Te traz uma cacetada de coisas que você pode fazer.
Eu comecei a fazer, isso ele trouxe a estrutura de whoapers colors e quebrando todo, aquele fluxo, de, deg gigantesco ali em ambientes de pródica, e aí.
Exatamente exatamente.
Se, trouxe um insight, que eu vi agora há pouco não sei se é essa a intenção é a última pergunta para fechar você começou a trazer o conceito de make até para trazer o determinismo para os evals também.
E, é interessante pensar em levar, isso até a nível de esteira também.
Sim, eu levo o livro de esteira também.
Então acho que acho que.
Ela. Eu tento se.
Se elaizar tudo.
Porque vira mais determinística e ajuda muito no processo de Devops.
Is, exatamente.
Eu observei isso depois que se postou aí o brief spec o taskpack tudo com clá, tá dando determinismo pra gente nem, pensa, mais só, executa, clá e que está um workflow ali determinístico.
Exatamente exatamente.
Maravilh.
Pronto. Você entendeu o que é principal? Você já passou de passou de ano. Já.
Você já entendeu. é isso.
é exatamente isso. Por quê?
Porque o agente é não determinísco se dá um esquio para ele.
Ele vai entender como se comportar. Mas daí você precisa dar para ele uma execução. E aí você dá para Ele O Quê Uma Cieli Para Ele Fazer.
Que abstraída é Mutiharnes. Qualquer um pode usar. E você só instrui o passo a passo em cima dele.
André. Pode perguntar.
Eu sei que a ferramenta em tese, faz o que divide lá ele executa o codecs executa o mypye só que não ficou muito claro se realmente ele. Está executando tem como você passar a compartilhar.
A configuração do homify.
Que, lá no, my pi tem as, configurações né, mcp as skill você consegue, passar isso para a gente.
Não mas sem nenhum problema.
Não agora, mas depois eu posso passar. Pois você me chama. Eu passo para você. Porque assim no Boot Camp, A Gente Vai Fazer Esse Setup.
Então eu posso parar ali um pouquinho e fazer o setup para você do on mypie, por exemplo, que é Simples Na Verdade Tá Não Tem Nada De Mais Não Mas A Gente Pode Fazer Sim.
Se puder passar antes do booticamp, porque eu queria pelo menos.
Gerar dúvidas para o boticamp conseguir tirar todas elas.
Sim, beleza. A gente conversa. Então offline.
Davi, meu querido.
Follow consegue me ouvir.
Consigo. Muito bem.
Maravilha ô luan é muito legal tudo que você está mostrando para a gente essa semana mas, eu vejo que.
Você está trabalhando só, em muitos projetos.
Você está tendo, a experiência ou está tendo, alguma dificuldade como você está tratando isso em projetos com outros agents engineers trabalhando no mesmo projeto, em test diferentes como que você está sincronizando essas, tests para que.
O seu agente não sobre escreva o trabalho de outro como que você está trabalhando com o kim.
Tá. é.
Eu acho que até não sei se eu mostrei para a Cru de vocês, mas como que eu trabalho com Outros Engenheiros Sim Estou.
é.
Como funciona basicamente assim.
Então, basicamente, esse é o meu processo que eu guio a galera. Eu não sei se você. Se eu já Tinha Te Mostrado Mas Senão Eu Passo Aqui De Novo.
Mas é legal para vocês verem. Então, por exemplo, o que o Davi falou pô legal, tudo isso. Mas.
Na vida real. Quando você for trabalhar ali com várias Llm diferentes.
Com vários processos. Como que vai acontecer? O processo de desenvolvimento tá.
Depois eles têm vários outros processos de code review e assim por diante. Então esse aqui é um pedaço do negócio.
Então imagina que você tem um repositório.
Então você está lá na meia ou na Master.
E aí a gente vai trabalhar.
Na ideia de sim. Swim, lens Legs e Tasks.
E aí uma Suene Lane.
é front end, por exemplo.
Então eu vou criar uma Branch front end.
Beleza. E vamos supor que dentro dessa Branch de Front End, vamos trabalhar. Duas pessoas.
Para ficar bem claro. Isso. Ah, só Brent, não.
O que você vai fazer quando você começar?
Dentro dessa brente, você vai criar um Work Tree.
Vamos supor que nessa Work Tree, você vai trabalhar uma logo do front end.
E nessa outra work Tree, você vai trabalhar um mock up da página. O mocapzinho da página.
A imagem da página. Do que é.
Então aqui o que você vai fazer? Você vai criar duas work tres.
Que pode estar para duas pessoas. Enfim.
E os seus agentes vão enterrar nesse book trade.
Boa.
Que está completamente isolada.
Cem isolada. Então elas vão trabalhar aqui? Beleza, terminei a logo. Terminei a logo.
Esse cara vai puxar.
Para a feature. E daí? Vai haver um processo de pull Request para mim que vai ter ciência.
Depois vai ter a esteira. Vai ter prefly check. Vai ter.
Code Review. Tudo que vai acontecer para ir para lá. Então isso aqui funciona muito bem.
Muito bem. Mesmo.
Legal essa divisão de walk tree você, quem faz ou você delega para ia fazer essa divisão.
Não é? Eu que faço isso aqui. é o que faço.
There you? Go.
Legal.
O que eu faço.
Segredo é org.
Valeu obrigado.
Valora.
Andrei.
Mutts.
Alô alô davin.
Hello, Hello, Sto.
Minha grande dúvida é sobre o, processo.
Projeto grande, quanto mais você vai fazendo, investigações ali quanto mais você abre o escopo do seu contrato de investigação como que você faz essa interação em cima dos documentos, que já estão criados por exemplo você começou investigando.
Uma coisa e teve um insight. Mas, um pouco mais, para frente você descobriu outra coisa como que você faz para acumular essas informações sem deixar o, contexto.
Defasado digamos, assim.
Duas formas. Se eu tiver em Investigation Mode, por exemplo, no seu caso, eu faço duas coisas.
Toda vez que eu bato uma bifurcação.
Eu crio um fork. Então eu estou trabalhando lá numa sessão.
Entendi que essa sessão vai ser explicada em duas. Falar, cara. Aqui eu estou cuidando disso. Mas eu achei outro problema.
Eu não vou poluir. Então eu faço duas coisas. Ou eu já faço um fork daquilo.
Você faz um forque, ele pega o contexto inteiro e deixa os contextos iguais em duas sessões diferentes.
E você continua.
Eu gosto disso para algumas coisas. Porque às vezes essa bifurcação.
é legal você ter o contexto anterior, porque eles vão entender a mesma coisa e vão seguir de lá com o contexto. Diferentes.
às vezes, quando eu estou em Deep Investigation, eu gosto de ter processos intermediários.
Então eu tenho lá, por exemplo.
Uma pasta Storage que aí eu guardo todos esses arquivos que eu estou trabalhando. Então eu estou trabalhando.
Cheguei, dei um checkpoint lá, cara. Grava pra mim as informações da sua investigação. Pum.
Depois vou lá. Abro outro cara. Trabalho, cara.
Grava no outro arquivo. As informações de investigação.
E aí eu tenho o conceito de orquestrador Worker. às vezes eu tenho uma orquestrador.
Gerando os prompts para os workers acharem o problema.
E aí esses workers escrevem no local. E depois o orquestrador valida essa informação.
é um Parten.
Show de bola.
Você pode usar.
Deixa, eu.
Rodrigo!
Isso. Não.
Boa a minha dúvida é na apresentação você, comentou que parou de usar o std então nesse cenário apresentado aqui você não utiliza, mais o agente spec certo, ou seja. Esse novo modelo seria, a evolução do agente spec aquele projetinho.
Eu não vou chamar de evolução. Vou falar que depende do propósito. Por exemplo.
O meu propósito final. Aqui.
é criar um processo contínuo de evolução.
Então vou dar o exemplo para você. No nosso contexto do problema. Ali.
O cara quer um ambiente analítico para responder as informações. Enfim.
Quando você criar um ambiente analítico, você vai ter requisições acontecendo toda hora. Então você vai querer criar uma fábrica Autônoma Que Vai Pegar Destilar A Intenção Criar Tarefa Blá Blá Blá E Fazer Isso Constantemente.
O espectro de Development. Você também pode fazer isso.
Mas ele é muito bom para quando você está construindo features.
Que não necessariamente. Vão estar dentro de um flywhealth, por exemplo.
Então, às vezes eu entro num projeto, e eu quero desenvolver uma feature.
E aí vai ser muito mais interessante para mim que eu quero desenvolver uma ficha somente.
Utilizar um Specimen Development. Em vez de utilizar uma parada de compilar intenção de compor atividade. Eu não preciso desse nível de complexidade.
Então eu ainda acho que o Spectriven Development é muito bom.
Mas no caso, meu.
Que a gente vai construir fábricas e processos que são autônomos e que rodam e assim por diante.
Nesse caso, o óbito utilizar mais um framework de intenção, mas cada um tem o seu caso de uso e Tem A Sua Necessidade Com Certeza.
Is it.
Boa volume.
Galera. é isso. Amanhã a gente vai ver.
A maior parte que.
Eu vejo muita coisa no X.
Eu vejo muita gente falando, mas eu não vejo aplicabilidade.
Então vocês vão ver loop e voz: Tá.
Então é uma sessão que eu não perderia.
Porque ela é literalmente o fechamento da gente. Ter uma roda contínua de trabalho.
E vocês vão prender literalmente, na prática sobre loop, voz. E ainda vou trazer um pouquinho de grafo para vocês, tá.
Então não perdem. Não, porque está foda a apresentação amanhã. Beleza.
Fica com Deus. Valeu. E até daqui a pouco, daqui a pouco a gente está ajuda de novo.
Até mais.